Das war's für heute.
Das wars für heute.
Vor allem weil der Clark N
wo ich bin keywords
hier
Nachrichten drin oder so
Zwei Jahre streamen soll und kein Partner. Oh ne ich hab's gestern noch nicht gemacht ne
Ich habe gestern noch nicht mal eine Partnerbewerbung abgeschickt
Ich weiß, ich weiß. Aber heut nach dem Stream mach ich's. Heute nach dem Stream wird's abgeschickt
Mal gucken wann der Stream heute vorbei ist. Mal gucken.
Den den ich gestern gehostet hab, hat den zufällig noch einer eine Weile geguckt
Ich hab nämlich mal am Ende, irgendwann als ich ins Bett gegangen bin, hab ich den Stream aufgemacht
Den mach ich immer noch on. Der war echt ausdauernd. Der war irgendwie sechs Stunden mindestens immer on
Also solange am Stück könnte ich nicht hier Brogers machen. Ich glaub die Musik ist immer noch ein ticken laut
Ja so ist das gut. Vielleicht muss ich auf Deutsch programmieren. Ja das wird's sein. Das wird's sein gehe ich auch von aus
Äh was hat man als Partner für Vorteile? Ich zeig's dir. Naja nicht nur. Also du kriegst, also du kriegst, du kannst abonnieren und du kriegst halt Emotes
Das ist so das größte, das wichtigste. Du kannst damit Geld verdienen, indem ich Leute abonnieren dürfen. Es gibt drei Abostufen
Es gibt einen für, es gibt einen Tier 1, 2, 3 Sub. Das kostet glaube ich 5 Dollar, 9 Dollar, 24 Dollar
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nie jemanden ein Tier 3 Sub gegeben. Ich weiß es nicht. 24, ja ok. Ok 24, 99. Das ist ja im Endeffekt 25
Huge Money. Und man kriegt Emotes für. Das ist eigentlich das wichtigste bei der ganzen Geschichte. Man kriegt bestimmt noch jede Menge andere gerade
Ich glaub man kann Bits und Cheeren und hast du nicht alles gesehen. Aber das wichtigste ist eigentlich Emotes. Warum ist hier so ein großer Platz bei Google?
Ach wegen ihrem kacke Logo. Huge Money. Hyokun. Huge. Massive. Ich dann 3 Abos. Kriegst ja 15 Dollar. Moment das stimmt ja nicht, weil ich 15 Dollar krieg. Ich krieg ja nur die Hälfte
Welche Programmiersprache kannst du? Das müssen wir mal aufnehmen. Ich muss mir da mal Gedanken zu machen und das müssen wir mal aufnehmen, weil die Frage kommt oft
Das machen wir jetzt mal schnell. Mal kurz in mich gehen. Was für Programmiersprachen kann ich denn? Leute ihr habt mich ja C und C++ Wursten sehen. Würdet ihr sagen das darf ich unter Kannich abstempeln?
Ich mein Kannich heißt nicht man ist Experte oder so. Sondern ich krieg damit halt was hin. Ok fangen wir mal an. Proggers Sprachen. Ich mag ja besonders Tabs die automatisch aufgehen
Ja. Nein. Ja. Nein. Also aktuell ist 2 zu 2. Ich sag mal ja. Also meine Lieblingssprache. Also meine Lieblingssprache ist so zweigeteilt. Zwei geteilt.
Übrigens mal eingeworfen. Ne verrate ich nachher. Oder was heißt verrate ich? Frag ich euch danach. Also meine Lieblingssprache bin ich so 2 geteilt. Richtig tibet.
Also meine Lieblingssprache bin ich 2 geteilt. Vom Framework und an sich drum herum ist sie scharf mit.NET. Allerdings. Ich mag auch Ruby sehr gerne als Programmiersprache.
Leider ist Ruby in den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen abgekackt. Also neue Ruby Projekte gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr so. Also ganz wenig.
Aber nämlich mal hier auf GitHub sucht nach keine Ahnung. Temp. Wir gehen einfach mal voraus. Temp gibt es in jedem Programm. Und da gucken wir mal hier. Guck mal da unten. Ruby. Ruby ist ganz. JavaScript ist ganz oben.
Und danach kommen die üblichen Verdächtigen. JavaScript ist ganz oben. Ist klar. Gefolgt von Java und Python. Ist klar. HTML. So. C++, PHP. Ruby. Vor ein paar Jahren sah das noch ganz anders aus.
Also mit neuen Sachen. Da war Ruby voll angesagt. Aber es ist ein bisschen abgekackt. Das liegt auch daran, weil Python so erfolgreich ist im AI Sektor, im Forschungs Sektor, im Web Anwendung.
Also Python hat sich ziemlich breit gemacht und ist auch eine ziemlich gute Sprache. Wobei ich. Also wir können ja noch mal. Ich könnte ja noch mal dahinter schreiben wie gut ich einschätzen würde.
Progress. Wie gut ich einschätzen würde, dass ich die ganzen Krams kann. Das machen wir danach. Das machen wir danach. Okay. Ganz wichtig wenn man was mit Linux macht. Shell. Shell in der Regel Bash. Weil.
Die Sachen die Bash da dazu gefügt hat wie diese Fake Arrays in der Shell und sowas sind schon ganz praktisch. Ja. C++. Wobei da wie gesagt bin ich kein großer Profi.
JavaScript, CSS, HTML. Wobei ich da jetzt auch nicht so oder so der krasse Owner bin. Groovy kann ich noch. Das ist die einzige Java Sprache die ich kann. Kann ich da noch. Kann ein bisschen Power Shell.
Vergesst die Hälfte des PAP. Ja PAP. PAP habe ich damals für meinen Battlefield Server habe ich so eine Stats Page gemacht. Falls irgendjemand damals auf meinem Battlefield Server gespielt hat.
Da habe ich eine Stats Page für die Leute gemacht. Den PAP. Alle die auf dem Server gespielt haben. Das war eigentlich ganz nice. Also jeder hatte quasi so ein Stats Profil.
Wir wurden getrackt. Rust. Rust. Rust habe ich auch schon was mit gemacht. Go. Nein. Go habe ich. Ich habe ein bisschen mal rumgespielt mit Go. Aber da würde ich nicht sagen dass ich damit was auf die Reihe kriege.
Dein BF3 Stream Server. Ne ne viel viel früher. Das war ein Xbox Server. Nein Java kann ich nicht. Das war ein Xbox Server. Da hatte ich eine PAP Seite gemacht.
Man konnte. Man kann hier. Warte mal war das ein Xbox Server. Nee Schwachsinn. Xbox Server konnte man vielleicht gar nicht drauf connecten. Dart. Dart kann ich auch nicht. Ich weiß das Dart und Flutter Scala auch nicht.
Nein Assembler würde ich nicht sagen. Da würde ich nicht können. Also ich meine wir können es mal dabei schreiben. Ja wir können wir können wir können mal. Ich schreibt ich schreibe wie gut ich denke dass ich was kann. Dahinter aber also.
Man hat sich das letzte Mal gesehen. Das war sehr kompliziert wo ich da mal was in Assembler gebastelt habe. Ja Dart und Flutter ist voll angesagt. Ich habe gesehen die haben auf der letzten. Das ist übelst übelst huge. Ja also das ist.
Richtig richtig nice. Die haben auf ihrer letzten Konferenz haben die angekündigt dass Flutter jetzt für Desktop funktioniert.
Und nicht damit. Die haben irgendwie. Das haben die. Ich weiß ich weiß ich wie das heißt. Ich habe letztes Video zugesehen.
Da haben sie gezeigt dass du jetzt ganz offiziell zwar offiziell ist es noch beta aber dass du jetzt Desktop Anwendungen mit Flutter machen kannst. Linux Mac Windows. Das ist extrem nice. Das ist wirklich nice.
Weil ganz ehrlich eine Sache die der Welt wirklich noch fehlt ist ein ordentliches Cross Plattform GUI Framework.
Das nicht Elektron ist und das nicht C++ ist. Es gibt ja nichts. Ihr sagt nicht es gibt was weil wenn ihr sagt es gibt was dann müsst ihr auch sagen was.
Und meiner Ansicht nach gibt es nichts Gescheites. Es gibt Elektron und es gibt Qt. Das wars aus Plattform ernst zu nehmen.
Ich habe nichts prinzipiell gegen C++. Allerdings ist C++ nicht die Sprache in der ich jetzt gerne komplette Anwendungen mache.
Ich habe letztens einen Vortrag gesehen. Qt ist übelst nice. Das ist das ist doch nicht. Das ist ich würde sagen mit meinem Lieblings GUI Framework und Qt geht weil das sehr viel eigenes macht was nicht so Standard C++ mäßig ist.
Ja Qt Chat. Aber ich hätte gerne noch irgendwas was anderes dazu. Aber Qt ist wirklich nicht schlecht. Die wissen leider nicht so genau.
Ich finde es ein bisschen verwirrend vor allem weil sie jetzt auf ihrem QML Trip mit JavaScript und so sind.
Das finde ich auf der einen Seite gut und auf der anderen Seite wieder ein bisschen doof weil das ist das ist ganz nice. Aber dann musste dann C++ Interop damit machen was dann wiederum irgendwie ein bisschen eklig ist.
Also es wäre schön wenn es da was aus einem Guss gäbe und was richtig nice wäre wenn es auch ein paar Bindings für unterschiedliche Sprachen geben würde.
Und ich habe letztens einen Web. Wie nennt man das? Wie nennt man so einen Konferenzmitschnitt? So ein Watt von der Konferenz gesehen.
Da hat einer Blazor gezeigt. Das ist von Microsoft einen. Kennt ihr das? Das ist von Microsoft Blazor. Das ist ein ASP.NET quasi für den Browser.
Also eine ganz merkwürdige Geschichte. Das ist quasi ein WebAssembly Client-Site ASP.NET Ding von Microsoft.
Und das haben sie gezeigt wie man das nicht nur im Browser laufen lassen kann sondern auch mit Flutter.
Was im Umkehrschluss heißen würde, wenn das ordentlich funktioniert, könnte man in Zukunft tatsächlich halbwegs ordentliche Internetanwendungen Cross-Plattform Buoy mit Flutter machen.
Also ich meine ganz ehrlich Flutter ist super nice was ich gesehen habe wie man das Interface erstellt.
Das ist ein bisschen wie HTML plus ohne den ganzen Crap drum herum. Ist wirklich nice. Und da, wenn da ist die Sharp.NET runter. Das war übelst nice.
Übrigens denkt man, wenn ich was übersehe, schreibt es mit Adwoblors, weil sonst taucht es in meinem Tool nicht auf.
Der Plutonam sagt, ich denke, dass MSP.NET 5 was Cross-Plattformen rausbringen wird ankündigen.
Da habe ich mal eine Zweifel, ob Microsoft Cross-Plattform GUI probieren wird.
Die sind sich ja unter Windows auch nicht mal einig, was für eine GUI jetzt angesagt ist.
Ey Windows ist der GUI wild und ich weiß gar nicht was mit Microsoft abgeht ey.
Windows ist der GUI Wildwuchs und Technologien Wildwuchs Deluxe.
Guckt euch nur mal in Windows an. Ihr müsst hier nur mal irgendwie Control eingeben. Altes Control Panel, neues Control Panel.
Komische neuen, komischen neuen Dingsanwendungen. Wie heißen sie?
Woops, dann dieses komische Fenster Shake Feature. Ah wie heißt der Kram nochmal? Ich habe es vergessen.
Die haben auch alles für ihren Scheiß eigenen Namen.
Fluent Design? Nee, nee, nee. Doch Fluent Design ist das oder?
Was sie sich jetzt neu ausgedacht haben für OVP. Was du jetzt allerdings auch in WPF und so verwenden kannst.
Also Windows ist von Microsofts Seite übelst nicht, ich glaube Fluent Design nennt sich das Ganze jetzt.
Ja, das ist das, dass die Anwendungen jetzt quasi so schön transparent sind und hast du nicht gesehen.
Zumindest Windows an sich ist schon der übelste Wildwuchs was GUI angeht.
Du hast ja auch dann selbst wiederum zig verschiedene Technologien die du verwenden kannst unter Windows, die Microsoft supportet.
Ich meine du hast die uralte Windows Geschichte, du kannst ja immer noch Windows von Hand machen.
Dann hast du quasi als Wrapper nochmal Windows Form drum herum.
Dann hast du diese, diese habe ich nie verwendet, diese MFC Geschichte für C++.
Dann hast du irgendwelche internen C++ Geschichten die beispielsweise Word verwendet.
Dann hast du WPF, dann hast du OVP.
Es ist ja so schlimm Microsoft verwendet den Kram ja selbst schon nicht mal konsequent.
Der Visual Studio Installer ist glaube ich Electron, vergesst mich wenn ich falsch liege.
Es ist ganz, es ist super wir.
So und nachdem Microsoft das ja selbst noch nicht mal geschissen kriegt unter Windows,
mal für einheitliches GUI und eine einheitliche GUI Technologie zu sorgen,
weil OVP ist ja immer noch keine Alternative für ordentliche Anwendungen.
Du kannst in OVP keine Screenshots machen.
Ich meine 2019.
Das ist der Witz oder?
So und deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass Microsoft einen Cross-Platform GUI Framework anbieten wird.
Ich würde es ihnen zutrauen, also schaffen würden sie, können tun die das auf jeden Fall.
Aber nachdem sie es ja noch nicht mal auf ihre eigenen Plattformen geschissen kriegen,
habe ich meine Bedenken, dass Microsoft das Cross-Platform geschissen kriegt.
Zumal unter Mac, unter Mac sieht alles was nicht,
Cocoa heißt das glaube ich, das Standard Zeug von Mac,
für alles was nicht Native Mac ist sieht unter,
Native Mac und zum Teil noch Browser,
sieht alles scheiße aus.
Das Problem hast du auch.
Guckt euch mal eine GTK Anwendung unter Mac an.
Das ist ja, das, das, das.
Mir fällt kein Vergleich zu einem wie das aussieht.
Das sieht aber auf jeden Fall Mist aus.
Oder guckt euch eine GTK Anwendung unter Windows an, das reicht schon.
Guckt euch eine Qt Anwendung unter Mac an.
Die sieht dann ein bisschen aus wie Mac, aber schreit an allen Ecken und endlich bin ich Mac.
Was ist deiner Meinung nach beste GUI für C-Sharp?
Also ganz ehrlich,
ich bin eigentlich für UWP,
allerdings das Problem mit UWP ist, dass du halt es nicht gebrauchen kannst für ordentliche Anwendungen.
Wie gesagt, du kannst bis heute keine Screenshots machen in UWP.
Deswegen bin ich in dem Fall für Windows Forms,
weil es einfach ist und WPF kann auch einfach sein,
aber WPF machen sie immer so eine riesige Glaubensgeschichte drum herum.
Bei WPF ist es so, wenn du in deine GUI Dateien Code reinschreibst,
flippen die ganzen WPF Best Practice Leute instant aus.
So nach dem Motto, ich brauche eine App, die ein Fenster hat und mir drei Zahlen anzeigt,
dann schreit der WPF Typ direkt rum, wenn du das in die Code behind machst.
Da sagt der WPF Typ dann, oh mein Gott, wie kannst du das in die Code behind Datei schreiben?
Da musst du mal hier mindestens MVWZ und 30 Milliarden Frameworks dazwischen machen,
dass du ein Fenster starten darfst.
Deswegen, ich bin für Windows Forms.
Windows Forms ist eine gute Abstraktion über Native Windows Geschiss
und an sich wären wir UWP aber am liebsten.
UWP ist sehr angenehm zu verwenden, allerdings ist das Problem,
dass UWP halt vieles nicht kann, was man braucht.
Ja und leider, man muss sich ja mal überlegen, wo uns das Ganze hingebracht hat.
Das hat uns unter anderem dahin gebracht,
dass die beste Alternative für Desktop Apps mittlerweile nicht etwa Qt ist.
Qt ist keine Alternative schlicht und ergreifend, weil es ganz billig gesagt C und C++ ist.
Das ist von der Technik her nicht schlecht, allerdings der Verbreitung tut es jetzt nicht gerade gut.
Ja und Qt hat immer noch ein paar Wirren,
ich habe da mal eine Weile relativ viel mit gemacht,
ein paar Wirren was die unterschiedlichen Plattformen angeht.
Zum Beispiel konnte das Textfeld in Qt lange Zeit keine Emojis von Windows einfügen und sowas.
Und dann hat es das Textfeld gebugged, ganz merkwürdig.
Aber da sind sie dabei, was auch ein Problem ist, wenn du Qt startest unter Windows.
Warte mal, habe ich das installiert?
Mach SideTrackSource am Start, ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Wir machen jetzt eine MiniQt Anwendung.
Ich zeige euch mal was ich meine mit Wirren.
Wobei gibt es das nicht vielleicht?
Leute ihr müsst euch merken, was ich mich bei einem SideTracken lasse,
dass ich dann wieder das noch aufgreifen kann.
Nee gibt es nicht, gibt es nicht.
Da müsst ihr das runterladen.
Aber wo haben wir uns hin geführt, dass Qt keine Alternative ist,
dass Microsoft nicht genau weiß, was bei ihnen abgeht GUI technisch,
dass Apple prinzipiell den eigenen Crap macht,
zum Beispiel mit Metal als Grafikapi,
dass es immer mehr Mobile Zeugs gibt
und dass es vielleicht flatter in Zukunft kein ordentliches Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework gibt.
Wo haben wir uns das hin geführt?
Dahin, dass die beste Alternative, die wir aktuell haben,
für Cross-Plattform-GUI-Anwendungen,
die auch ordentlich funktioniert, Elektron ist.
Also im Prinzip ein Chrome in einem eigenen Fenster
mit jeder Menge AVA-Skriptrumme rum.
Ich finde immer nie den Download-Kopfknopf für Qt.
Das ist super, super hidden.
Was, bei Mac gibt es doch Unity?
Ich weiß nicht, was Unity unter Mac ist.
Ich kenne nur Unity als Game Engine.
Und ja, der Witz ist, fass mal auf,
ich habe sogar schon ernsthafte Diskussionen drüber gehört,
wo Leute gesagt haben, sie wollen Unity, also die Game Engine,
als Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework verwenden,
weil es nichts gibt.
Und dann haben die Leute gesagt,
sie wollen Unity, also die Game Engine, als Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework verwenden,
weil es nichts gibt.
Nix gescheit, also nichts gescheit native gibt.
Das ist eigentlich der Witz.
Macht zwar keiner, der irgendwie dabei verstanden ist,
aber allein sieht man, wie verzweifelt die Leute sind.
Qt-Online-Installer, blablabla.
Skip, ich zeige euch jetzt nämlich mal,
was das Problem damit ist.
Ich hoffe, das Problem gibt es noch, sonst ist es gut,
wenn es das Problem nicht mehr gibt.
Also die Plattform-Wirren, die Qt so ein bisschen hat.
So, next.
Was ist die aktuellste Version?
Q13.
Ich brauche Q13 für...
Ja, ja, komm jetzt mal nicht die ganze Zeit.
Ich brauche Q13 für Microsoft-Compiler,
64-Spit.
Leicht.
Und Qt-Creator soll er installieren.
Das geht schnell, der Download.
Das ist...
What? No.
Abort. Nicht abbrechen.
Ach, jetzt hat er wieder mal ein OBS gekillt.
Er ist gekillt.
Geht's wieder?
Jetzt geht's wieder, ne?
Ich musste den Installerfahrt ändern.
Wo ändert man den Installerfahrt?
Next.
Skip.
Und jetzt einfach nur, dass ich euch zeigen kann,
wie Qt rumspackt.
Ach, da.
Nicht C-Doppelpunkt-Windows,
sondern Stream.
Qt.
Next.
Für Microsoft-Compiler.
Ich hoffe, den habe ich überhaupt installiert.
C-Doppelpunkt-Eye-Eye-Eye.
Lul.
Next.
Yes.
Yap.
Are you ready?
Yes.
Das war's für heute.
welches render back end verwendet das standardmäßig weil die sache war die
Moment moment das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren
Alter wenn ich wenn ich sowas hier schon zähne
Wer wer hat sich überlegt
vom C++ standard cremium
dass das so dass das eine schöne syntax ist und das ist noch nicht mal schlimm
das ist das ist noch schön das ist schönes C++ das ist noch nicht mal
schlimm in C++ gibt ja so komische dinge wie sowas wie wie konst und und blub
und so dinge wo ich mir denke was soll das überhaupt sein
das sind irgendwelche R-values und sowas warte mal also um euch jetzt noch mal zu
erklären was das problem war in alten versionen hatste
warum will das netzwerk zugriff piss dich netzwerk also fürs debugging wahrscheinlich
hat das gesehen es hat geflimmert das hat die haben das problem immer noch es hat
geleckt oder geflimmert je nachdem was man gemacht hat ich glaube wir müssen
wir müssen da mal wir müssen was was rein machen
rectangle euch kann kein qml aus dem kopf ich glaube aus dem kopf keine
ahnung 500 ok moment ich muss mir eine cute qml rectangle background kopieren
oder wir machen einfach wir können einfach neues projekt man weil das hat
das hat das hat gebackt du hast in qt das problem entweder hat das resizing
geleckt wie helle oder der background hat geflimmert ohne ende
ja rectangle gibt es da
qt creator ist eigentlich nee nee nee nee nee das ist ok
wir machen das jetzt einfach so ich will jetzt heute gar keine cute programmieren
aber nee die haben das gefixt die haben das gefixt
machen wir mal ein anderes beispiel das wäre extrem nice so eben haben wir 13
genommen wir nehmen jetzt mal 10 ach nee das ist minimal required
die haben es gefixt ich glaube es nicht wahnsinn nach fünf jahren
ok dass die fall von trainering sieht immer noch mist aus aber das kann man
umstellen ich habe es gefühlt das ist echt das ist echt nice also das problem
war dass die bisher immer dass die übelstes resize lag hatten aber aber
richtiges lag ich muss das muss ich mir nach dem stream oder so muss ich mir das
noch mal in einem nächsten stil vielleicht machen wir mal eine kleine cute
anwendung und gucken uns das an die cute anwendung wenn wir dann aber eier ja
und lassen das ding eine eier ja animation abspielen oder so was aus dem
chat los und das andere problem war wenn das resize mich geleckt hat dann hat
der hintergrund geflimmert wie sau und es hat auch unterschiedlich geleckt ob
man so wie es heißt oder oder so wie es heißt übrigens jetzt jetzt fangfrage
hat jemand eine idee warum es unterschiedlich leckt ob man so wie
es heißt oder so wie es heißt ist eigentlich logisch wenn man drüber
nachdenken aber so ein bisschen sind in interaktion hier wenn man so wie es heißt
war das lag besser als wenn man so wie es heißt
erdkörmung ja fast geht schon in die richtige richtung
ich schenke mir was neues zu trinken das problem ist also was ich mir denken
kann was ich nicht was ich offiziell im backtracker steht also das problem ist
dass du die ganzen grafik background gedöns mal angenommen du hast du hast
ein buffer für alle pixel ja du kannst super den vergrößern also ne du hast
hier 00 koordinate oben links du kannst ohne probleme den buffer vergrößern
was dran hängen wenn du allerdings jetzt hier oben quasi den punkt wo 00 ist
ändert dann musste glaube ich die ganze anwendung den kompletten buffer
resizen ich denke mal dass so was der hintergrund gewesen sein muss dass da
zumindest man konnte das fixen in cute früher auch schon
hallo da gedus man kann das in gut früher auch schon fixen
werden man wurde mal kurz bleck ja aber das ist nichts im vergleich zu früher
das ist nix das hat das das hat vorher das das das das hat vorher geflimmert
wie wenn einer wie die kennt ihr die die in half life kennt ihr die diese
headcrab zombies da gibt es im ersten level von half life so was wo sie
damals schon probleme hatten für leute mit epilepsie wo die wo so flimmert so
sah das aus im hintergrund wenn du das resize hast früher
obei unten könnte es noch ein bisschen flimmern das ok das echt ok so und was
du früher machen konntest ist oder machen musstest du musstest entweder
sagen ich will software rendering haben dann konntest du keinen web browser
verwenden weil der cute web browser also die die cute web engine funktioniert
bloß mit mit einem 3d render renderer ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken dass
sich zusammen zusammen kriege du konntest auch das becken umstellen auf
also standardmäßig ist es nämlich open gl hatten sie die ganze zeit aber wir
gucken mal wir stellen es auf open gel um vielleicht vielleicht ist es dann
vielleicht ist das problem wieder drin ich weiß allerdings nicht mal wie das
funktioniert hat standardmäßig haben sie früher open gel zum rendern
verwenden das war unter windows crap vielleicht sind auch einfach die
nvidia treiber mittlerweile besser so und dann konntest du es zurückstellen auf
da ich 11 das hat nichts gebracht auf 10 hat nichts gebracht erst mit 9 hat es
halbwegs funktioniert allerdings dass es mit direkt x verwendet werden konnte
musstest du einen einen open gel zu direkt x rapper irgendwie verwenden
nennt nannte sich engel und damit lief es echt gut aber damit hat sie dann
probleme dass das wieder andere sachen nicht richtig funktioniert aber es war
voll für den arsch es war richtig kacke das heißt wenn es jetzt die folgmäßig
richtig gut funktioniert wäre echt sehr nice und wird er dazu führen dass ich
tatsächlich wieder mehr mit cute machen wird wie konnte wie hat man den cute
noch mal das backhand umgestellt
zockst du noch was also in letzter zeit spiele ich eigentlich jede menge ist
alles alle zeug wieder
ich muss mal gucken wie man das umgestellt hat
wie man ob die l
muss man gucken ich will es ja sehen mich mal auf ob die er auf auf auf
open gel umstellen gucken ob der back immer noch da ist
hier cutie engel in die engel plattform wollten wir nicht ich will nicht
eigentlich will ich will ganz normal open gel verwenden
die ganzen abis kann es doch kein mensch im kopf merken
war das war das set attribute irgendwas in der richtung dass man sagen konnte gl
ne auch fack
wie hat man dem ding noch mal gesagt dass der gel verwenden soll
origin braucht cute web gedöns ja ja origin ist eine cute anwendung mit cute
web engine drin ich habe da sogar mal ein video drüber gemacht wo ich die
developer tools für origin eingeschaltet hat das war eigentlich
ganz lustig dann kommt man in origin in den developer tools rumklicken
forz open gel
ich wusste heute kurz in mich gehen ah ja das da da konnte man das da konnte
man es auf jeden fall forcen dass es open gel verwendet so mit open gel hatte
das halt riesige probleme unter windows die letzten version mal gucken wie es
jetzt ist das geht aber schnell das ist ja nice das funktioniert huge okay ich
bin begeistert für begeistert das hat absolut nichts mit dem zu tun was ich
heute machen wollte aber ich bin begeistert dass es die probleme nicht
mehr gibt schieben geht auch rezaisten geht auch ohne probleme es leckt auch
oder so was was glaube ich was weiß ich auch immer kannst du was kannst du was
zu webentwicklung in 2019 sagen speziell was aktuell state of the art für
backend und frontend ist also ich bin jetzt nicht der super experte was web
was web anwendung angeht wie man ja unter anderem ja auch hier sieht dass
meine maus rumpacken wobei die maus sind nur gefakt die kommen gar nicht so
direkt aus der anwendung aber nicht weiter sagen also aktuell sehe ich zwei
große trends was web und wenn was webentwicklung angeht zum ersten mal
nach wie vor also frontend zum zum zum ersten mal nach wie vor natürlich ganz
viel javascript und so zeug wie angular react und view das ist nach wie vor
angesagt view ist jetzt das neueste davon den drei großen allerdings mögen
dass die entwickler allerdings im businessbereich ist es eher react und
angular was die meisten da verwenden falls wir webentwickler hier haben könnte
könnte gerne im chat was zu schreiben wie ihr das seht der zweite trend bei
webentwicklung im frontend den ich sehe ist dass jetzt so nach und nach immer
mehr sachen kommen die die es schon lange gibt die allerdings ihren weg in
den browser finden über webassembly also sprich zum beispiel gibt es jetzt ja
habe ich ja vorhin gezeigt playser von microsoft quasi eine dotnet umgebung
für den browser also du kannst mit playser dotnet
programme im browser laufen lassen kleinzeitig über webassembly also das
ist so der zweite trend den ich an der ganz nex cloud schon zu ende
knerbeer überlegt mal ich bin 56 minuten on gab es schon mal irgendeinen stream
wo ich in den ersten 56 minuten überhaupt schon mal richtig angefangen
hat mit dem thema
ganz gute übersicht für webentwicklung ach das kenne ich das kenne ich aber
das ist wirklich ein guter link den der true elbow gepostet hat es
gibt ein paar so sachen es gibt auch so ein paar linksammlung die nennen sich
dann meistens awesome blabla web development awesome dotnet core und so
was
da haben leute dann so ein paar sachen zusammengefasst in dem fall geht es
hier wahrscheinlich um ne das doch was anderes die kenne ich doch nicht
was für technologien man kennen sollte im web in der webentwicklung sieht aber
auch ziemlich brauchbar aus ja und zumal das ding hat 84.000 sterne auf github
das kann nicht so schlecht sein
genau das sind die zwei sachen die ich in puncto frontend sehe aktuell
so als trends und ich bin mal wirklich gespannt drauf was da noch über was
da noch webassembly technisch kommt also was für klassische sachen mit
demnächst im browser laufen haben die musik ist vorbei weil wir können was
anderes noch anmachen egal ich muss jetzt mal nicht vergesse wieder was ich sagen
wollte dass da noch viel mehr klassische sachen in browser kommen über web
assembly als also die letzten jahre war letzten jahre war im endeffekt web
entwicklung dadurch immer wieder neu was es halt für javascript frameworks
und tools gab und es ist es vergeht ja in der webentwicklung quasi kein tag wo
nicht irgendein typ neues web framework rausbringt oder ein neues npm alternative
oder ein neues tool xy oder den neuen mini feier oder was weiß ich ja also
webentwicklung da ist da ist er teufel los und jeder ist der meinung er muss da
irgendwelche halbfertigen tools auf github veröffentlichen und sagen hier
jungs guck mal da und da wird das ganze aufgegriffen auf hacker news und reddit
und alle erzählen war geil neues tool super light weight ganz toll ganz schnell
und super viel besser als der alte grab allerdings fehlen noch ein paar features
dann werden die features eingebauten dass das neue genauso scheiße wie das alte
aber das ist das kommt in javascript relativ oft vor und wenn man auf github
guckt javascript ist nicht ohne grund die meistverbreitete sprache auf
aktuell auf github allerdings wie gesagt dort net kommt in den browser jetzt über
webassembly und es gibt auch schon einen rust compiler für webassembly habe ich
gesehen cc++ bestimmt auch allerdings das schöne an blazer ist dass es nicht
einfach nur dort net für den browser dass das muss ich mal aufschreiben das
könnten wir übrigens mal in einem da könnten wir übrigens mal ein stream zu
machen blazer habe ich jetzt noch nicht großartig ausprobiert das schöne an
blazer ist es ist nicht nur ein komplettes dort net quasi für ein browser
sondern es ist ein komplettes quasi web ui framework also du kannst damit
wirklich webseiten bauen es ist noch nicht so schnell wie
beispielsweise css htm javascript ist logisch das ist ja noch relativ neu und
das braucht bestimmt auch noch ein paar optimierung es ist auch aktuell nicht so
einfach webseiten zu manipulieren von webassembly raus allerdings ich denke
mal das wird sich in den nächsten jahren schon auch schon noch in die richtige
richtung entwickeln und ich denke auch dass das die zukunft sein wird was
backend angeht eigentlich das was am einfachsten ist also der trend bei
webanwendung geht eindeutig dahin dass man oder schon die letzten jahre oder
die letzten fünf jahre zehn jahre fast schon geht dahin dass man auf dem
server selbst eigentlich kein html mehr macht also keine html rendern oder so
sondern dass man quasi nur ein paar ap endpunkte hat die jason zeugs raushauen
und den rest macht man hauptsächlich kleinseitig ausnahmen bestätigen die
regel und 100 prozent davon oder 100 prozent also 100 prozent backer 100
prozent kleiner der weg der realistische weg liegt irgendwo dazwischen ja aber
der trend geht ganz klar dahin dass man das backend logik machen lässt und in
endpunkt hat der jason raushaut und alles was frontend angeht macht man auch
im frontend das war lange zeit nicht so lange zeit hast du ja eben in deinem
server in deinem backend für deine web anwendung hast du html quasi aufbereitet
für den klein dass er das dann anzeigen kann das macht man heute eigentlich sehr
selten noch was du da im backend verwendest ist ganz ehrlich leben das
was am einfachsten ist am verbreitetsten ist eindeutig wobei würde
ich mal gar nicht sagen dass das eindeutig ist zumindest wenn du wenn du
leute suchst kannst du auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt wenn du wenn du was
suchst was verbreitet ist zum lernen kannst du mit not mit not und den
üblichen weiß nicht was in not so die üblichen server framework sind express
oder sowas ganz auf jeden fall nicht nicht nix verkehrt machen
auch noch verbreitet seit eunis pp kannst du eigentlich auch relativ wenig
verkehrt machen auch wenn die meisten web entwickler sagen pp aber mittlerweile
pp ist gar nicht wild ja also pp ist nicht verkehrt facebook läuft zum
größten alle mit pfp weiß ich dass das dürfte das einzige positive an facebook
sein und ansonsten so die klassischen sachen wie asp.net und sowas ist
natürlich auch angesagt nehmen im backend einfach das was für deinen zweck
das einfachste ist ich würde da gar keine große glaubensfrage drumherum
machen und das einfachste ist in der regel das was du am besten kannst und
wenn du was kleines brauchst hat es keinen sinn dass du jetzt irgendwie den
riesen web framework nimmst dann macht eine pyson flask anwendung oder sowas
wenn du einfach nur auf drei urls fünf verschiedene textausgaben brauchst da
nehme ich was kleines
so viel zum thema web anwendung
gsp ist weiß ich nicht wie aktuell wie angesagt das noch ist ich habe ehrlich
gesagt lange nichts mehr zum thema java und web anwendung gehört aber java ist
so ein ding das wird immer verwendet ohne dass groß drüber geredet wird
warum benutzt du scoop und nicht coca choco das ist eine gute frage weil
scoop rein rein user basiert ist also der saut nur in meinem heimatverzeichnungs
rum und nicht systemweit und ist für developer software eigentlich am besten
wir haben alles drin exel der salami prinz unser exel programmer salami
prinz erinnert mich ein bisschen an hertutorial ist nextcloud auf deinem pay
glaube mal nein weil du das bei nicht gut verschlossener aktuell ist
nextcloud bei mir auf der 4h e-kiste noch drauf aber das soll ja darunter und ich
bin ich bin eigentlich überhaupt nicht zufrieden mit nextcloud deswegen wollte
ich mir heute mal die neueste nextcloud version angucken und mal schauen ob das
noch ob das mir jetzt besser gefällt
hast gelten kann ich nicht nee ich weiß was es ist eine funktionale brücke
programmiersprache aber kann ich nicht das ist die einzige funktionale
programmiersprache wo ich ein bisschen ein bisschen aber wirklich nur ganz
ein bisschen was drin gemacht habe ist f-scharp bisher die das aber so wenig dass
ich noch nicht mal in meiner liste hier aufnehmen würde
mit das ist eine frage die kommt auch öfters vielleicht vielleicht können
auch ein komando draus machen in welcher programmiersprache hast du angefangen
also das erste mal in kontakt so richtig damit gekommen bin ich mit mit c
allerdings fand ich das damals scheiße deswegen empfehle ich auch keine mit c
anzufangen es war nur so eine sache von der
schule und wahrscheinlich war das ein ehemaliger mathelehrer der halt nur ein
bisschen c konnte das war für den arsch da habe ich auch nichts gelernt und da
konnte ich auch nichts danach außer dass ich programmieren scheiße fand ich das
ist nämlich das problem wenn man mit sprachen anfängt die für einsteiger
eben zu große hürden haben oder zu abstrakt sind oder zu low level sind oder
zu zu wenig bling bling für einsteiger haben haben die danach kein bock mehr
so richtig angefangen habe ich da nicht haben wir noch ein pausenbuch geholt
und ab damit rum gebastelt und wusste dann allerdings nicht so recht mir hat
es super spaß gemacht was zu programmieren allerdings wusste nicht so
recht was damit anfangen soll und da bin ich dann auf idee kommen ich würde mal
gerne ein paar windows desktop anwendungen machen
weil mich interessiert hat wie funktioniert das überhaupt wie macht
man hier sowas da und dann habe ich mir einfach damals studio runtergeladen und
das kostenlose c sharp dotnet galileo open book was es übrigens heute noch
gibt und eine super sache ist wenn man mit c sharp anfangen will gibt es in der
letzten ausgabe immer noch kostenlos bei openpress und seitdem muss ich sagen
das war das war zu dotnet zwei zeiten da war dotnet 2 grad relativ neu mit
generics und sowas das ist schon ein bisschen her
man wartet dotnet zwei release mal gucken kann ich dir sagen
ok bristles studio 2005 also so ungefähr 2005 2006 war das ist also schon ein
bisschen her und ich muss sagen seitdem seitdem ist dotnet eigentlich obwohl ich
ja eigentlich überhaupt kein microsoft fan bin in der in der in dem sinne ist
dotnet meine lieblings plattform geblieben und sie scharf wie gesagt ich
mich mal ich programmiere auch gerne was den ruby und sonst was
allerdings insgesamt würde ich sagen seit anfang an ist eigentlich und da ist
das sagt schon viel über die über so einen framework eine sprache aus dass
sie einiges richtig gemacht haben müssen meine meine lieblingssprache geblieben
bist du alt ja ich bin nächsten monat 35 so
programmiere ja endlich darauf gewartet ok leute wollen wir noch ein paar stellen
anzeigen rosten oder wollen wir mit next cloud anfangen
posten wir machen aber nicht viele na ich hab mir gedacht es ist so was was man
immer mal zwischendurch im stream machen kann immer dann wenn wenn man sich
ein bisschen ausruhen muss so nach dem motto als haben wir was
gemacht das haben wir ein bisschen bisschen viel geschwätzt ein bisschen war
zu anstrengend jetzt können wir uns ein paar stellenanzeigen angucken
next cloud das geht ja nicht 20 minuten oder so
die dusseldorf ist bis sie weit weg also nach köln wobei kommt drauf an also
kommt auch an wie die anwendung ist nach köln brauche ich eine stunde ungefähr
reine fahrzeit vom hauptbahnhof also wird es wahrscheinlich nach dusseldorf
also mit welcher unter eine halbe stunde nicht über nicht unterwegs sein
das müsste sich dann aber wirklich richtig lohnen dass jeden tag eine halbe
stunde fahren würde und wahrscheinlich mit der bahn eher zwei
stunden je nachdem wo das ist wo das liegt
ok wir fangen mal an mit der mit der sache wo ich die lustigsten job anzeigen
immer finde das ist meistens golem jobs ich weiß nicht ob bei golem jobs nur
komische firmen inserieren oder so aber da finde ich irgendwie immer die lustigsten
sachen
der autofahren kommt bei mir nicht in frage ich will damit öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel hinkommen also nicht in frage würde ich nicht sagen also wenn
das natürlich so was super geiles ist ja ok 603 29 ist frankfurt und wir suchen
jetzt mal so der fox so voll voll modern
ok was haben wir hier der fox engineer weiß männlich deutsch das passt doch
wenn das einer klippt dann ist jeder sind die feministen am start
nein es ist natürlich weiblich männlich diverse ja
ich sag ja so immer gerne ob die leute bisschen zu dringern weiß männlich
deutsch
habe ich jetzt die ersten paar aufgemacht das da das da das da der
denik der denik so immer noch leute das war einer das war einer der drei die
letztes jahr wo jemand geschrieben hat dass die leute suchen so immer noch ich
wollte mich da echt bewerben ich wollte mich ich wollte mich ernsthaft bei
denik bewerben habe ich aber ihr wisst ich bin übelst faul
obwohl davon ok was haben wir so
ok gut dass die man muss sich überlegen die meisten stellen anzeigen sind von
irgendwelchen human resources typen gebastelt ja also sprich von
irgendwelchen personal abteilungsleuten oder recruiting typen die halt von neben
was in der stellenbeschreibung gefordert wird keine ahnung haben wenn man
glück hat fragen sie diejenigen die ahnung haben
ansonsten kommt was ganz merkwürdig ist bei raus hast du gefragt ob du über das
gehalt reden darf wo gefragt auf der arbeit naja also nachdem ich wiss wo ich
arbeite ist das wahrscheinlich kein problem aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das
großartig erzählen will denik wäre bestimmt geiler arbeitgeber
moment nicht beim d6 sorry leute beim d6 wollte ich mich bewerben nicht bei der
denik jetzt habe ich durcheinander geschmissen
beides jahre nicht weit beim d6 wollte ich mich bewerben
jetzt habe ich durcheinander geschmissen
ok gucken wir uns das mal an also das schreiben alle rein dass sie der dass
sie es gibt kaum kaum eine webseite von irgendwelchen unternehmen wo nicht drauf
steht dass sie in irgendwas der führende anbieter sind die frage ist
viel eher was interessiert mich das in der stellen ist das ist das irgendwie
wichtig für mich egal vom material mit mehr als 30.000 höchste effizienz bar
steuerung von logistik ihre marken linde materialhändling stiften fenn wick
in dem habe ich nie gehört aber kann sein ich kann mich auch in in der
branche nicht aus zu in welcher branche sind die dann was wozu gehört das denn
materialhändling lösung kann ich mir überhaupt nichts runter vorstellen wenn ich
ehrlich bin was materialhändling lösungen sind als technisches herz
das konzern ja ok denn digitalisierung gehört bei uns war unsere
mitarbeiter kombinieren technologische expertise mit geschäftssinn oder bin ich
da falsche für also wenn ich die auswahl hab zwischen ich machs zum cash
kreppen oder ich machs technisch ausgefeilt
dann mache ich es eher technisch ausgefeilt als zum kohle kreppen aus
diesem grunde wollen wir experten die dynamically brokern sind was auch immer
das genau heißen mag was jetzt was stellt ihr euch darunter vor also
also man genommen ich würde es jetzt nicht im stream lesen sondern ich würde
jetzt wirklich suchen so nach dem motto ich habe jetzt habe jetzt ganz billig
gesagt man hätte jetzt seine ausbildung fertig und sucht was oder oder keine
markt gekündigt man wurde gekickt was auch immer und man sucht was man liest
das jetzt also das heißt man muss sich wirklich damit beschäftigen was könnte
dynamically programm gemeint sein leute die besonders flexibel sind leute die
leute wollen die leute die besonders flexibel sind vielleicht also sprich
die rüberstunden arbeiten und egal kommen wir weiter das ist ja eigentlich
das interessante ihre aufgaben als dev ops engineer sind sie für die
automatisierung der bild release deployment testprozesse verantwortlich
das würde ja von der stellen beschreibung ja ziemlich gut auf das
zutreffen was ich aktuell mache das würde das würde gut passen ja sie
entwickeln und verbessern monitoring lösung kann ich auch machen würde ich
auch gerne machen bin ich ok sie betreuen als teil des teams unsere
anwendung gut ich meine ich betreue als teil des teams unsere betreuen nicht die
anwendung sondern ich bin teil eines teams der die anwendung betreut und da
ist man natürlich als der forst schon der richtige wir sind verantwortlich
für die optimierung der continuous integration und continuous delivery
pipeline pipeline auf basis von cloud und container technologie also ich muss
sagen die aufgaben klingen ganz klassisch nach so was hier also klassisch
kann man von klassisch kann man den fall sprechen ist ja nicht so dass das
ja schon so super lang gibt aber zumindest die aufgaben passen schon mal
zu dem was sie suchen das finde ich schon mal gut das ist bei den meisten
stellenanzeigen nicht so bei den meisten stellenanzeigen suchen sie
eigentlich drei leute und schreiben nur ein titel um hin
ok ihr profil euer profil sie verfügen bei einer abgeschlossenen ausbildung oder
überall abgeschlossener schuld ja sie bringen erfahrung in der
automatisierung von prozessen für die entwicklung nach dem prinzip von
kindes ja sie sind vertraut im umgang mit containerisierung defops
automatisierungstool docker ansible schenkenswirt ja also mit allem sie
haben erfahrung in agilen metoden wie beispielsweise scrum ja wenn was
richtig die frage ist das ist so ein ding das ist so ein scrum schreiben
sie alle gerne immerhin auf auf ihre weil weil alle es sagen heute alle sie
sind agil es ist heute überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt wenn man nicht agil ist
ja also jeder sagt sie sind agil man sieht aber relativ selten dass das auch
wirklich wirklich gemacht wird also
es gibt genug genug lehen und da war ich mal bei einem die verstehen unter scrum
wir stellen uns einmal am tag für eine viertel stunde in einen raum und jeder
sagt was er gerade macht und man darf nicht sitzen
das ist zwar ein bisschen teil von der ganzen geschichte allerdings
bei weiter ist nicht der kern dessen ja und ansonsten macht man einfach alles
ganz normal das ist nicht scrum das ist wir sagen wir machen das ohne dass wir
es machen
also für mich für mich ist agil eigentlich dass es um um die leute im
team geht dass es um die ideen der leute im team die dass es um die
kommunikation der leute in in im team untereinander geht dass es kurze
abstände gibt also dass man nicht sagt okay wir entwickeln jetzt ein halbes
java center verschlossenen türen dass es kurze abstände gibt dass es kurze
sprints wie sie es immerhin gibt wo dann geguckt wird ok was brauchen wir noch
was machen wir noch dass das halt alles ein bisschen wie nennt man das so schön
kontinuous ist ja user sorry sowas in der richtung ja die user stories ist
auch so ein ding das kann man komplett in die in die in die torne treten wenn
man es nicht richtig macht eine user story ist zum beispiel also ist wenn man
sich wenn man sich quasi in die rolle dass jenigen rein versetzt der das dann
benutzen will so nach dem motto ich als support mitarbeiter möchte schnell alle
kunden daten finden so ganz kurz das wäre eine user story zum beispiel
ja und das kann man sich dann als thema nehmen oder davon gibt es mehrere user
stories man kann es dann auch so machen dass man sich überlegt auf welche user
stories verteilen wir jetzt irgendwie die leute oder man kann sogar die
leute das selbst irgendwie bestimmen lassen was was sie für wichtig halten
weil wie gesagt beim für mich geht es bei den ganzen agilen sachen eigentlich
um die leute in dem team drinnen dass die sich kreativ daran beteiligen können
an der ganzen sache im gegensatz zu herkömmlichen planungsmethoden ja ok sie
haben idealerweise bereits erfahrung mit der er hat auch das ist ja fast wie
gemacht für mich sie kommunizieren im internationalen umfeld deutsch und
englisch sicher wie all sitting in one boat kriege ich auch gebacken wenn es
sein muss wir bieten ein börsen mit erstklassige mal jetzt jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was was was b was gibt es denn tolles
das ist echt eine frage er schreibt ich würde gerne wissen wie die user stories
bei dais und action aussehen user stories bei dais und activision sehen aus ich
als user habe zu wenig skins zu kaufen wann gibt es neue so in der richtung
ein börsnotiertes unternehmen mit erstklassigen ganz ehrlich das schreiben
viele in die in die in diese sache wir bieten das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
vollkommen wurscht
das hat das sagt für meinen für meinen job da überhaupt nichts aus umfassende
einarbeitung ihren aufgabenbereich das würde ich ja mal das würde ich nicht
unter wir bieten schreiben umfassende einarbeitung in ihren aufgabenbereich
das ist das ist schon unter basic eigentlich ich meine erwartet wirklich
jemanden was man sich irgendwo hinsetzt so eine einarbeitung man automatisch
weiß was man machen soll es gibt eigentlich keinen sinn oder
spannende aufgaben und ein kollegiales miteinander
ich würde mal hoffen dass keine spasten dabei sind das war sozusagen wir hatten
schon wir hatten bei uns auf der arbeit und da wo ich vorher war auch schon
genug deppen ja also ich würde mal hoffen dass die meisten läden heute
mittlerweile wert darauf legen dass die leute jetzt sozial nicht ganz
unbrauchbar sind ich meine ihr wisst ich mag keine menschen das habe ich schon
oft genug gesagt ja aber ich komme die leuten aus
vor allem wenn sie mich nicht nerven und mir nicht auf den keks gehen mit
irgendwas
und und auf diesem niveau sollte das eigentlich jeder hinkriegen
attraktive vergütung sowie zusätzliche sozialleistung
also wenn es eine betriebliche altersvorsorge gäbe oder oder
berufsunfähigkeit da würde das wahrscheinlich drinne stehen denke ich
mal wahrscheinlich sind die zusätzlichen sozialen leistungen nur das was sie
gesetzlich machen müssen attraktive vergütung sagt nichts aus
sagt jeder
sagt nichts also im prinzip sind alle vier punkte unter wir bieten komplett
für die hohle hand also im prinzip bieten sie nichts wenn man so will laut
dieser stellenanzeige betriebliche renten sind miss da riecht das kommt
drauf an wenn du eine betriebliche alter ich habe das ja auch gemacht und zwar
aus einem grund weil nicht nur du ein bezahlt sondern fast fast noch mal das
gleiche vom arbeitgeber mit ein bezahlt wird und ich war damals extra bei einem
beratungstyp weil ich von sowas keine ahnung habe ich war damals extra bei
einem beratungstyp bei einem honorar beratungstyp wohlgemerkt nicht bei einem
der was aufschmerzen will und habe ihm das den vertrag gezeigt die sache was
sie anbieten bei mir hat er gesagt das lohnt sich in dem fall auf jeden fall
deswegen habe ich das gemacht allerdings ist es bei mir jetzt abgelaufen das
heißt das war auch der grund warum ich die letzten jahre immer gesagt habe ich
bin jetzt erst mal auf unbestimmte zeit gebunden dran aber wie gesagt seit
januar diesen jahres ist das nicht mehr so jetzt jetzt könnte ich wieder wenn ich
denn wollen würde sie wollen in einem agilen umfeld
gemeinsam mit international teams exzellente IT services liefern ehrlich
gesagt wenn die mich fragen würden was ich was ich was ich will das heißt ich
will erst mal ordentlich geld haben das ist eigentlich so die grundsätzliche sache ich
gehe nicht hin um irgendwie die welt besser zu machen oder
da ich gehe da erst mal hin um was ordentliches zu verdienen und natürlich
das in kombination mit dass die arbeit auch was auch spaß macht und interessante
themen hatten so klar das bevorzugt ja jeder aber also wenn sie mich fragen was
ich will dann ist erstmal ordentliches gehalten
interesse geweckt also ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen also mit diesem wir bieten
haben sie mein interesse nicht geweckt auch wenn das hier fast eins zu eins wie
die faust aufs auge zu dem passen würde was ich mache wo ich erfahrung drin
habe wo ich wo ich über zehn jahre erfahrung drin habe was ich alles kann und
was also vom profil her zu 95 prozent auf mich passen würde
würde ich jetzt sagen also also dass wir bieten hat mich jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig überzeugt interesse geweckt alter was ist das für eine mail
da nämlich die pro kräft vielleicht guckt man irgendwann noch mal so als
nächstes also dass wir bieten war warten wir wirklich nicht so überzeugt
achso stimmt statt da eigentlich was die suchen also meine ich suche die suchen
ja wohl offensichtlich denn intern sonst würden sie das hier nicht
reinschreiben aber da steht auch nichts von projekten oder so drin also ich
suche nur wirklich jemand der da langfristig bleibt ok als nächstes was
haben jetzt die fein analytisch technologisch quanti quantitativ also
ist das quasi quasi mehr masse statt klasse oder
was ist man wenn man quantitativ ist
quantitativ der menge anzahl
ist man dann sick im großen stil auch das ist eine schöne übersetzung davon
ja bei tagslauf seit unbefristet einsatz aus deutschland frankfurter mein zum
nächstmöglichsten zeitpunkt nächstmöglicher zeitpunkt überlegen keine
ahnung wenn das bei mir stopp drei monate
ich glaube ich habe drei monate zwei monate weiß gar nicht die fein ist ein
führendes europäisches beratungsunternehmen mit standorten in
berlin blablabla damit das schreibt die stimmt da kommt bestimmt auch wieder dass
sie dass sie führend in einem bereich sind oder so mit über 800 qualifizierten
beratern unterstützen unsere kunden bankenversicherungen gut wir sind in
frankfurt also natürlich bankenversicherungen
industrie oder was sonst bei anspruchs bei anspruchsvollen quantitativen
prozesse prozessualen und technologischen anforderungen das
schreit so ein bisschen eitel oder
strategieberatung fachberatung technologieberatung ist ist alles in
einem
der technische support unsere mitarbeiter von einem internen abt ja bleiben durchgeführt
suchen die suchen die support support leute
die von wegs und um den hohen qualitätsanspruch von beratern und
internen mitarbeiter an unser team auf weiter zu füllen suchen wir für unseren
hauptsitz in frankfurt am ein zum nächstmöglichen zeitpunkt ein defops engineer
in vollzeit ok also was soll man machen aufgaben
verantwortung für die installation betrieb travel shooting von system
das ist entweder ein server admin oder einen support mit dabei ich glaube
nicht dass sie den defops engineer suchen ok administration unterschiedlicher
server unter darauf installierten applikationen entwicklung von
lösungsansätze und durchführung interner projekte
optimierung der IT strukturen entsprechend aber moment was genau suchen
die das ist das ist so eine typische anzeige die eigentlich drei leute in
einem suchen die suchen den support mitarbeiter die suchen den server admin
die suchen den projekt manager und die suchen einen organisator typus und
organisator eitel mensch also eigentlich suchen die vier sachen die suchen die
suchen eigentlich so in die vier stellen und ich mein ja defops ist von
mehreren bereichen etwas allerdings geht es nicht darum dass man vier personen
in einem ist
also das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn also das ist schon so komplett rote
karte wenn du eine überschrift siehst was sie suchen und in den aufgaben sich
das erstes mit der mit der stellen beschreiben also mit dem mit dem mit der
position nicht deckt und die aufgaben auch miteinander nichts zu tun haben wie
gesagt das hier ist eher so eine support
geschichte das ist eine server admin geschichte das ist eine das beides es
ist so eine so eine so eine projekt management eitel geschichte also naja
anforderung abgeschlosses studium oder ausbildung in der bereiche der know-how
in der administration der gängigen server betriebssysteme was sind dann die
gängigen server betriebssysteme bei euch
das ist also dass das ist eine anzeige die hat jemand von der personalabteilung
geschrieben da keine ahnung hat was was sie eigentlich wollen
das ist 100 pro sowas die wissen die also derjenige die anzeige geschrieben
hat weiß nicht was was sie eigentlich haben wollen
dem haben sie bloß gesagt wir brauchen jemand der das und das kann oder haben
sie so eine so eine so eine anzeige draus gestrickt
ich meine gängigen server betriebssysteme das hört sich erst mal
simpel an ist es aber vor allem im umfeld wie banken und so was gar nicht
das kann ibl mainframe sein das also mit exotischen sachen anzufangen ja das
könnt ibl mainframe host gedürnt sein das könnte noch uralt ja ich zum
beispiel oder sonst was sein das könnte natürlich auch wenn das
und linux sein allerdings du wirst keinen finden der alle vier sachen gut kann
und ich meine so ein host administriert sich auch ein bisschen anders als in
linux oder noch mal anders als in windows oder so ein alles ex und
virtualisierungsumgebung gibt es auch mehrere sachen ist es microsoft ist es
ist es vmwahr wahrscheinlich ist es vmwahr weil vmwahr im businessbereich so
das verbreitet aber man weiß es nicht was mich wieder dazu dem schluss bringt
dass das irgendein personalabteilungstyp geschrieben hat oder
personalabteilungsfrau geschrieben hat oder personalabteilungsdivers geschrieben
hat der keine ahnung was sie eigentlich haben wollen
kenntnisse im umgang mit der microsoft basierten IT infrastruktur
insbesondere exchange und active directory das ist das nix für mich
ich bin es wird ja immer schlimmer ach du scheiße
idealerweise verfügen sie über datenbank und oder scriptingkenntnis sowie erfahrene
amitra von sharepoint und skype for business monka giga wartet leute
ich muss mich erschießen
ich muss mich erschießen also eine sache da müsste ich schon kurz vor
verhungern sein dass ich skype for business administrator werden würde
oder aber oder aber die geben mir 150.000 im jahr
wobei selbst dafür würde ich mir noch mal überlegen die geben mir 200.000 im
jahr dann dann würde ich auch skype for business administrieren
da würde ich komplett lohnen und wäre mir das komplett egal
dann würde ich mich da acht stunden hinsetzen skype for business machen und
mit kohle wieder heimgehen und sagen drauf geschissen
praktische erfahrungen der administration und oder anwendungsbetreuung
sowie entsprechende zusatzqualifikationen sind von
praktische erfahrungen der administration also ich würde mal sagen
jemand der wie wie passt das denn zusammen also das ist das das ist
zwingend erforderlich praktische erfahrungen der administration wie sollst
du das dann sonst machen strukturierte eigensständiges gut das schreiben sie
alle motivation zur weiterentwicklung also bisher fand ich die erste stellen
anzeige richtig gut wo ich sagen die hier die hier nicht strukturierte
eigenständige service oder motivation zur weiterentwicklung der eigenen
erkenntnis und qualifikation wird schwierig wenn man quasi mann für alles
ist motivation also es heißt im prinzip es gibt keine schulung es erklärt dir
keiner was und du sollst dich nicht so anstellen wenn es in bereich ist von dem
du eigentlich keine ahnung hast sondern einfach machen
fähigkeit komplexe sachverhalte verständlich zu formulieren sehr gut
ok ok wir bieten da müssen sie jetzt aber da müssen sie jetzt mal richtig
reinhauen was sie bieten weil das da oben ist nun wirklich nicht überzeugend
einen modernen arbeitsplatz im herzen von frankfurt ja der herzen von frankfurt
ist das einzige was für mich relevant ist da dran das moderne arbeitsplatz
jetzt würde ich jetzt mal eigentlich von aus geht ein abwechslungsreich und
verantwortlich von ok standard standard floskel
flache hier archien und auch standard was viele immer so schreiben flache
hier archien sind übrigens oftmals gar nicht so flach wie sie glauben dass sie
sind das ist so ein bisschen wie es manche firmen gibt die so die sagen so
nach dem oder ja bei uns darf jeder zu jedem thema was sagen ja bis auf ein
party mehr sagen dürfen also es ist unrealistisch davon auszugehen dass das
dass die meisten so flach sind wie sie sich immer wie sie immer tun
das ist aber auch jetzt nix nix was man was man wirklich bietet ja so bietet
wer zum beispiel wenn einer sagt hey bei uns gibt es mittags kostenlos eis ganz
bescheuert das zu sagen aber das wäre was wo ich sagen würde das schon mal
nice ja das war es wirklich noch hey auf der anderen seite ganz ehrlich wenn
einer ein ordentliches gehalt bietet ist das schon mal die beste grundlage
dafür dass das ganze was wird freiraum und flexibilität bei der
persönlichen arbeitsgestaltung das ist so ein satz wo ich mir wo ich mir
gedanken machen würde das passt nämlich ein bisschen zu der
ganzen sache hier oben dass eigentlich keiner so wirklich dich wahrscheinlich
einarbeiten wird die sagen wird was du machst dass quasi von dir irgendwas
erwartet wird und keiner erklärt ihr jemals so genau was so liest sich das
für mich das ist kein das ist kein plus punkt und unter flexibilität verstehen
da viele so nach dem motto ich kann den typ samstag samstag mittags anrufen wenn
er gerade auf dem klo ist am kacken oder hat bestimmt keine probleme auch mal
irgendwie nach münchen zu fahren für drei tage und da irgendwie was
einzubauen oder so
attraktive sozialleistung 30 tage jahresurlaub als ist es jetzt der
attraktive sozialleistung dass die standard betriebliche altersvorsorge
ok das kann ganz gut sein fahrtkosten fahrtkosten zu das ist ganz nice
das ist das ist wirklich nicht verkehrt überstunden ausgleich das müssen sie
sogar machen also es sei denn man hat irgendeinen
speziellen vertrag und ich glaube selbst da wurden jetzt erst letztens noch ein
bisschen engere grenzen gesetzt ansonsten ist das ist das eigentlich
pflicht wenn du den arbeitsvertrag hast da stehen 40 stunden drin kann ich
einfach einer sagen wir aber in 60 stunden
individuelle trainingsmöglichkeiten regelmäßiges feedback
ok kann alles damit gemeint sein kann auch sein wir gehen regelmäßig auf den
sack weil wir noch mehr von ihr haben wollen tolle mitarbeiter events ok da
hat es bei mir schon auf
tolle mitarbeiter event sind in der regel nicht toll
ja also wenn man es jetzt gefallen kann sich an frau drollen wenden
nein machen wir nicht next also also das war hier das war gar nichts das war
wirklich gar nichts das war eher das war das war so eine passt alles nicht
zusammen
ich weiß mich juckt ja manchmal bei solchen sachen ja aber das kannst du
nicht machen das kannst du nicht im stream bringen da
eine mail hinzuschreiben mit mit ein paar nachfragen das ist
sucht max neuer job naja ich bin offen für neue sachen seit
1.1.2019 also seit anfang des jahres also wenn es was tolles neues gibt können
wir uns da gerne drüber austauschen
also ich habe was ich bin da auch nicht unzufrieden aber nicht großartig
unzufrieden es gibt ein paar sachen die nerven ist überall so außerdem sieht
das glas überall auch immer grüner aus aber wenn es irgendwie was in frankfurt
oder umgebung was was neues gibt was gut passt und was mir gefällt bin ich da
sofort dabei
wachs den ulm gibt es gut ich habe mal in ulm gearbeitet
wenn es darum geht die leistungsfähigkeit was take your chance
der fox engineer wie heißt die firma risk consulting ok salting wenn es
darum geht die leistungsfähigkeit von unternehmen zu stärken macht es niemand
so schnell macht uns niemand so schnell was vor als eines der deutschlandweit
führenden dienstleister haben was wieder das hat jeder irgendwie drin
steht als eines der deutschlandweit führenden
dienstleistungsunternehmen im cloud umfeld bieten wir renommierten kunden
darunter die erfolgreichsten namenhaften enterprise unternehmen heißt
enterprise nicht unternehmen was was heißt enterprise es heißt
unternehmen vielleicht doch egal consulting eine breite palette von
services und lösungen in den bereichen consulting development und operations
development und operations treiben wir die digitale transformation konsequent
voran unsere verantwortung reicht dabei von
der strategischen beratung über die ganzheitliche konzeption und
realisierung von projekten bis hin zum management der bestehenden it system
land schaffen was uns für dich als arbeitgeber
besonders macht das vertrauen in unser team professionell sowie kollegiale
leister das viel trägt verantwortung und beeinflusst wesentliche zukunft der risk
verstehe unter risk was anderes als in consulting unternehmen aber das
wahrscheinlich so eine it weiß aber ist das auf jeden fall mein problem nicht
dass nicht den erst die diskruten aber auch die eigentlich jeder einzelne ist
es wert in ihn zu investieren und wir investieren in die menschen profit
profitiere auch du von dieser investition in dich sofern die
investition so aussieht okay profitiere auch entwickle mit uns deine persönliche
zukunft weiter nachhaltig individuell das klingt jetzt zwar sehr nur nach 15
formuliert vom ansatz her finde ich das aber gar nicht schlecht wenn das denn
wirklich so ist und ich einfach nur nur nur hohles gelaber das auch noch mal
rauszustellen wenn es ihn wirklich um die leute geht gibt er tatsächlich leden
da sind die leute nicht da zum zum wegschmeißen oder die leute nicht da um
um irgendwas zu machen und danach zu sagen brauchen nicht mehr sondern die
haben wirklich vor mit den leuten auch langfristig zu arbeiten soll da vorkommen
dann ist es auch gar nicht schlecht wenn man das gleich reinschreibt
unbefristete fest an festanstellung am standort köln oder frankfurt vollzeit
sofort die haben wir ganz schön viel text hier du bist für die berufswelt
bereit und fühlt sich von dem gestellten aufgaben profil herausgefordert
kannst du eine entsprechende schulische bildung nach bis höflich kommunikativ
und willst dich zukunftsorientiert aufstellen dann ergreife deine
möglichkeit den optimal einstieg in die it von morgen zu sichern
wir bilden sich zum absoluten experten aus konsequent individuell und
inklosive zertifizierung
sein wissen war bestimmt ist da eine itale zertifizierung dabei
dein wissen und deine fachliche kompetenz erweiterst du durch intensive
trainings und
stetig im wissens
austausch in einem großen team
ok blabla was jetzt jetzt kommt als defops engineer arbeitest du an spannenden
fragestellungen innovativen projekten rund um die themen
die pläne und operation sind deswegen heißt es ja auch so
du verbesserst bestehende prozesse und entwickelt kontinuierlich an der
automatisierung im datacenter und in der klaut
im weiteren sind die möglichen aufgabenbereiche nur grob skizziert du
gestaltest die richtung
ja es wäre schon nicht schlecht wenn ihr wüsstet was ihr genau sucht
ich glaube das richtet sich eher an jemand der gratten frisch mit seiner
ausbildung fertig ist
ähm
verbesserung von konzepten und lösen im bereich von defops teams
integration und weiterentwicklung defops orientierten tools
kit puppet docker kupanetes terraform
ja ok das ist ja also
das da ist ja zur zeit übelst angesagt
dass da auch puppet ist
etabliert
das ist ein tool wurde sogar quasi
sogar automatisch reproduzierbar aufbauen kann es mit
und gibt es ist standard
durchführung von anforderungsanalysen hinsichtlich der technik ausgestellung
umsetzen neue strategien
möglich darunter vorstellen
ich würde ich würde schon prinzipiell zu den aufgaben von einem defops
engineer zählen wenn jemand
zu dir kommt und fragt
was sagst du dazu oder
oder wir haben hier was vor gibt man einen senf dazu
würde ich da schon würde ich da schon dazu zählen
aufgaben und bereitstellung von klaut infrastruktur
man baut ganze klauts auf
nicht schlecht
alter chat was ist los mit euch
migration klassische infrastruktur blablabla blablabla
begleitung der entwicklung neuer anwendung von in die bis zum operativen
die implementierung
implementierung der software löse innerhalb der klaut
teamarbeit in agil schuld auch das erweitern
ok das ist
irgendwie ziemlich nicht sagt
könnte ganz gut sein man weiß es nicht so genau
ich finde es ist auch ein bisschen residents lieber geschrieben
hat mich also spricht mich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig an
klick vor bennett wirds
kuck mal was die für fast die für fast die für vorteile haben
verpasst deiner karriere den richtigen kick
jetzt heißt es ist hier um hießen sie noch risk
wie heißen sie jetzt
als sie heißen risk und sie ist wahrscheinlich für consulting
risk consulting
was sind dann die vorteile blablabla blablabla blablabla
blablabla benefits ok
flexibel aber sein
das je nachdem wie sie es meinen kann es auch nicht unbedingt was guter sein
vertrauensarbeitszeit das kann auch was gutes und was schlechte sein bei den
meisten würde ich sagen ist es eher was schlechtes
das kann das kann beides sein
also ich würde aber eher mal nicht unbedingt jetzt in sowas gutem zählen
generell wenn wenn zu viel von flippen flexibilität und arbeitszeiten
geschrieben wird ist das für mich kein allzu gutes zeichen
also ich will schon damit planen können wenn ich sag
ich arbeite viel mehr als ich will
ich arbeite vier tage die woche drei tage oder fünf tage je nachdem
oder sagen wir mal ich arbeite irgendwie 32 stunden die woche zum beispiel
dann will ich auch mich darauf verlassen können dass ich in der regel 32 stunden
die woche arbeite
sonst würde ich einen 40 stunden vertrag abschließen
oder einen 50 stunden vertrag welches regelmäßig machen muss
es sollte wenn man das sollte die arbeitszeit die im vertrag drinne steht
sollte
also nicht nur die regel sein sondern sondern wirklich die die 95 prozent
regel sollte das sein
ansonsten
guck mal ich meine es ist doch eigentlich total beknackt
also
es kann gut und schlecht sein ja aber den meisten würde ich eher sagen es ist
nichts gutes wenn schon gleich was von flexibel arbeitszeiten drin steht
home office
das wiederum finde ich gut
wenn sie das gleich reinschreiben
unsere regel und biete die möglichkeit auf flexibel von zu hause je nach status
hat jeder mindestens zehn home office tage
zehn home office tage im kalenderjahr
zehn home office das ist doch kein pluspunkt home office
zehn tage
im jahr hätten die gesagt im monat
dann könnte man das da reinschreiben aber es kommt leute im jahr
im jahr
also wenn ich zehn home office tage im jahr standard habe dann würde ich nicht
home office bei mir überhaupt reinschreiben
wenn jemand einer sagt zehn tage im monat ok
dann habe ich meine home office tage im jahr und bei mir stand nirgends sowas von
großartig home office drin
hast du shortcuts für dein meboard ja steuerung l ist null zum beispiel steuerung m
ist monkaS
und steuerung 3 ist null 3d und steuerung g ist
ach weiß ich nicht mehr
ja aber es kann auch shortcuts
urlaub
also ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sie
wirklich die pflicht ist aber es sind gesetzlich vorgeschrieben sind entweder
26 oder 30 tage eins von beidem
ah 24
20 nein nein es sind mehr als 20 tage
zumindest ist 30 tage jetzt
standard eigentlich
das ist jetzt nichts außergewöhnliches
ist bei uns auch so
urlaubsanträge werden in der regel immer zügig für den beantragten
zeitpunkt genehmigt also dass urlaubsanträge in dem normalen raden
genehmigt werden das sollte sehr für eine sonneurlaub bildungsurlaub und
sabbaticals sind üblich doch entsprechend abzustimmen gut ist jetzt
auch nichts tolles
work life balance die vereinbarkeit von beruf und berater stellen
insbesondere im projekte
um diese herausfassung gehen wir auf bedürfnisse
egal ob ein projekteinsatz am wohnort gewünscht
ist
nein nein nein nein nein
ok
das ding wird schon mal für mich komplett komplett komplett flachfallen
komplett komplett komplett flachfallen
für mich sieht das nicht so aus als wäre ich gehörner priorität also
projekteinsatz am wohnort
vergiss es
ich habe keinen bock drei monate mich in münchen oder so
wobei münchen geht noch münchen ist eigentlich ganz nice ja
ich habe keinen bock drei monate irgendwo rumzugammeln am arsch der welt weil da
irgendein projekt ist
kinderbetreuung ist für mich egal
kantine
kantine brauchst du in frankfurt eigentlich nicht ist aber nice haben wir auch
es ist
genau 24 tage sind ja
stand auch gerade bei wikipedia
essenszulage
im office findet sich stets und kostenlos
äpfel bananen kiwi mandarinen traum
keine schnitzel
übrigens kinderbetreuung ist nicht verkehrt ja weil es der monat abaku gerade schreibt also
das ist auf jeden fall ein großer pluspunkt
der rest nicht so sehr
das hier ist auch ganz nice aber jetzt nichts wo ich sagen würde ja muss
unbedingt sein
gesundheitsmaßnahmen
ja auch okay
das ist das ist auch ganz gut
haben wir auch
war ich einmal und wieder
nicht sofort für
günstige anbindung parkmöglichkeiten ist für mich
mobilität bahnkart okay das aber auch
zuschuss fahrkosten zuschuss ist gut oder job ticket das ist das ist das sind beide
sachen die die sind gut und die sparen auch geld und die die also die sind die
bringen richtig richtig was an kohle ja
wenn man zum beispiel ein ticket bezahlt kriegt oder zu zuschläge zu dem ticket
kriegt
100 euro im monat
das ist einfach schon mal 100 sind 1200 euro im jahr oder sagen wir mal wenn
monat 11.100 euro im jahr das ist schon mal ein bisschen was mitarbeiter handys
ja das ist kein vorteil
das ist kein vorteil das sieht nur so aus
ähm letztendlich ist das eine eine consulting beratungsfirma die wollen dass
du erreichbar bist das ist reiner selbstzweck mitarbeiter handys reiner
selbstzweck
internet nur zu mir sind
das ist das ist auch normal dass das man intern also ich weiß es gibt viele
firmen die in deutschland immer noch rum rum
fixen und machen und ich wollen dass mitarbeiter auch mal privat was im
internet gucken aber das finde ich ist 2019 vor allem bei einem unternehmen was
mit att was zu tun hat nicht mehr zeitgemäß
es ist vollkommen normal vor allem wenn du so auf auf flexibel und dynamisch und
sonst was machst dass ich selbstverständlich nebenbei
ähm
nen zweiten zweiten zweites zweites zweites Fenster auf haben kann wo wo ich
beispielsweise meinen privaten twitter feed oder so ab
also wenn man schon modern dynamisch ist dann sollte sowas standard sein
weiter bildung krauschen blablabla ok ehrlich gesagt eigentlich wurscht
spricht mich nicht an
bricht bricht ich sprich mich an
ok wir machen wir machen andere muss ich an
aber hier
klares gar nicht best schild
wo wo wo
haf die haf die abi gibt kein fick ok ein gucken wir noch da war dann machen
war dann war mein ex klaut pentasus
also wir hatten echt glück die erste stellenanzeige war ziemlich gut
hörst du noch deutscher ich hab noch nie wirklich großartig deutscher gehört
ich war das eigentlich immer nur zur belustigung die erste anzeige war echt
gut ich meine wir bieten war ein bisschen schwach aber der rest hat ein
rundes bild ergeben also das ist was wo man sich wo ich mir tatsächlich überlegen
kann ok da könnte man sich bewerben ja die andere die man bisher die anderen
zwei die haben mir nicht gefallen
ok was haben die hier denn zu bieten
das stellenangebot von wo davon hatten wir noch nicht das ist das letzte
wollen wir das noch gucken
wollen wir noch wo davon gucken bevor bevor nex klaut kommt
wir gucken jetzt erstmal die hier pentasus docker ist das für sie etwas
als ein hafen arbeiter
wenn es eigentlich davon ausgehen dass jemand das liest weiß was noch gar ist
der fall stand am münchen schuttgart fragen von wir sind pentasus wir
optimieren geschäftsprozesse durch smarte IT lösungen seit 20 jahren die
büros das gute unsere projekte werden immer viel zähliger und vielfältiger
das beste unsere kollegen und klingeln sind sie zumindest von überzeugt sind
schlecht viele neue kollegen für unser entwicklerteam zu suchen der fabs
engineers für kunden spezifische blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla
ok das muss man jetzt gar nicht lesen das ist sehr nicht sagen aber immerhin
bisschen fülltext ihre aufgaben ok ist eigentlich gedacht dass man das liest
so wir lesen es mal so mit spaß an der arbeit moderne klaut native soft das ist
auch so ein basswörter begriff klaut native kann keiner so genau erklären
was es ist na das ist genauso wie microservices kann ja auch keiner so
genau erklären wollen uns service anfängt und wurden microservice beginnt
und wurden microservice aufhören und service beginnt und so wie das halt mit
basswörz ist für den kunden entwickeln dabei die toolchain und umgebung
gestalten zum glück ist es nicht die blockchain sie arbeiten an modernen
klaut plattformen gestalten blablabla blablabla und gestalten also um
anwendung schnell auszurollen zu betreiben das ist alles schon das das
ist auf jeden fall schon mal mit dem mit der mit der stellenbeschreibung deckt
sich das ja anwendung schnell auszurollen und zu betreiben das ist
was was ich schon hier in diesem deff ops bereich zählen würde dabei sind
sie teil eines agilen teams ok das eigenständig kunden spezifische software
entwickelt und den betrieb gewährleistet ok passt auch die qualität gewährleisten
sie über moderne continuous integration continuous delivery umgebung in
kombination mit test und automatisierung alles passt dazu ist nicht so wie bei
dieser ein bei dieser einen stelle wo man drucke patronen tauschen sollte das
hat auch wenigstens mit deff ops zu tun unsere projektvielfalt als teil unserer
blablabla nutzen wir moderne aber das sind ja die microservices moderne
klaut infrastruktur und microsoft service architekturin ihre kenntnisse in der
objektorientierung in programmierung setzen sie mittels aktueller java sprach
features
intellijay ist zumindest nicht eclipse oder eclipse ich habe nicht weitergelesen
alter teufel weiche
ich brauche ich bräuchte noch so und so ein exorzisten emote
ok muss nicht schlecht sein wahrscheinlich eher nichts für mich
intellijay ist ist gut ja intellijay ist die einzige java ide die ich mag und dann
auch nicht für java zu entwickeln sondern mit dem rast plugin ist die für
rast ganz gut der milchmann hat übrigens recht also ist es schon mal gut dass hier
verschiedene ideen drinne stehen ja das ist das ist generell ein gutes zeichen
wenn irgendwo so was steht wie freie betriebssystemwahl freie ide wahl oder
sowas in der richtung das ist immer ein gutes zeichen für dass die das mit
agil auch so meinen wie sie sagen
perspektiven für deff ops engineers keine weiterentwicklung ist das aber
wir bieten ihnen flexible arbeitszeiten da haben wir es wieder
erfolgsbeteiligung das kann gut sein reiseprämie heißt dass die wollen das
mal wieder irgendwo rum hockt ein paar monate paar wochen
übernahme von reisekosten in vorn als das da so oft reisekosten drin vor dass
so drinne vorkommt ist immer so ein bisschen so ein bisschen so ein rotes tuch für mich weil
ich habe kein problem da irgendwie wenn man sagt hey der hauptsächlich standort
der firma ist sagen wir jetzt mal irgendwie in in münchen und zweimal im
jahr ist da irgendwie eine veranstaltung da müssen halt alle hin
das ist ok aber wenn da gleich was von leistungen und reise und sowas drinne
steht dann heißt es für mich eher als ist es so ein ding wie als hockste mal
in münchen mal in stuttgart mein frankfurt mein hamburg mein düsseldorf
mal nürnberg und mal bei einem kunde und sonst was das ist eher nicht nicht so
dass vermögenswirksame leistung na gut das müssen sie
ob das ist ok ich bin ich bin mir rechtlich nicht so sicher ob sie das
müssen aber es gibt zumindest keinen den ich kenne das nicht macht buch budget
pimp your it budget das heißt ich kann mir jetzt den ruby buch bestellen und
kriegt es bezahlt was natürlich wahrscheinlich krasse
investitionen für die firma suchst du einen neuen job oder guckst du einfach
mal ja ja nee also nee nee ja je nachdem also ich suche nicht wirklich einen
neuen job ich kann seit erst im ersten 2019 aber
einen neuen job suchen weil vorher konnte ich nicht also vorher war ich quasi vertraglich
so gebunden dass ich nicht konnte aber jetzt kann ich und ich will aber nicht
unbedingt es sei denn es gibt was geiles da bin ich bin ich dafür zu haben ja und
eigentlich haben wir nur aus spaß gesagt wir können uns bei ein paar
stellenanzeige angucken max kann man das als emote nehmen
ja das finde ich gut das finde ich gut als das finde ich ist das ist ein gutes
emote wenn wenn jemand was von java schreibt das problem ist man müsste
ihr könnt ja mal gucken ob es den auch transparent gibt ohne die küche im
keller
so wir gucken jetzt die anzeige noch fertig danach noch schnell vor und dann
machen wir nix klaut fack es ist schon alter es ist ja schon wieder ich bin
schon wieder zwei stunden und die zeit geht über übelst schnell rum
krass oder umfeld hoch qualifizieren okay blablabla
community fest feste gehören zum programm ich hasse menschen und hasse
feste
da gehe ich immer nicht hin wir haben auch weihnachtsfeier sommerfest
blabla mit dem außendienst fest hast du nicht gesehen fest bei uns gibt es alle
alle nase lang mal irgendwelche veranstaltung ich gehe immer nicht hin
ich bin halt keller kind
ob ist die musik auf einmal so laut
okay da gucken wir uns mal voran was voran so haben möchte
achso und die haben wir noch gar nicht fertig zu dazu noch interne coding dojos ja
das ist so eine was kann man sich darunter vorstellen das ist eine
veranstaltung wo du entweder irgendwelche aufgaben versucht möglichst
elegant zu lösen mit mit mit leuten zusammen es kommt drauf an was man da
macht ja oder im prinzip ist es ein bisschen so was wie eine weiterbildung
dann sitzt halt zusammen also was ich kenne ist dass man da so was nennt sich
dann katas das so ein bisschen so wie die krassen karate fighter leute macht
dass man sich zum beispiel dass man sich eine aufgabe sucht und versucht die dann
quasi gemeinsam besonders elegant oder besonders kurz und knackig besonders
elegant besonders schön zu lesen er zu lösen das macht spaß mit den richtigen
leute macht wirklich spaß also zum beispiel zum beispiel hier mein meine
mein mein mein chat chatprogramm hier na das ist so was das könnte man als
aufgabe nehmen das setzt man sich einfach mit fünf leuten hin und
überlegt sich hey wie kann man das möglichst kurz prägnant elegant machen
das wäre so ein beispiel so was dass man in so einem coding dojo machen könnte
es kommt ein bisschen drauf an was die jeweilige firma darunter versteht
anforderungen sie haben bereits erfahrungen mit containern wie docker mit
mindestens einer cloud plattform wie aws azure ja beides gcp ich glaube das
die google geschichte na kuba netes oder
wenn das passt alles das passt nicht so ganz zusammen das da kann ich ohne
probleme selbst hosten und es ist alleine keine cloud plattform dass da
sind wirklich cloud plattformen die wo ich keine alters drauf habe
auf linux systeme sind sie zu hause und virtualisieren auch für sie kein
fremdwort ja wenn ich wenn ich irgendwo zu hause bin dann sind linux systeme
am liebsten ist ihnen jedoch eine automatisierte umgebung in
infrastruktur es kommt immer drauf an für was sie sind zur not auch mit chef
oder ansebel bereitstellen ja kann ich auch machen sogar mit
beidem wenn es sein muss ist er ansebel chef und pappert pappert war ja in der in der
sache vorher drinnen in der stellenanzeige vorher schlägt alles in die
gleiche kerbe dass man konfig dateien erstellt für
einen für einen tool was dann wiederum anhand dieser konfig dateien systeme
automatisch bereit stellt und gleich aufbaut zudem bringen sie praktische
erfahrung in entwicklung von java nein oder noch gs ja basierten lösungen mit
ci cd tools wie jenkins ja klar gefällt mir nicht ok war da vorn wo ist war da
vorn
schon wieder die wo ist war da vorn war da vorn
ah die waren das hier also wurde vorn was ist mit infrastructure as code gemeint
das ist wieder so ein richtig eigentlich in ziemlich blöde bezeichnung mit
infrastructure as a code gemeint ist dass man eben zum beispiel so ein tool wie
ansebel chef oder pappert oder gibt es das soll stack und es gibt noch ein
paar andere dinge hat also quasi tools die anhand von source code systeme
provisionieren konfigurieren automatisch aufbauen und wenn man halt
diesen source code für diese tools nimmt und vielleicht noch in den git oder
inversionsverwaltung rein haut das ist im prinzip infrastructure infrastructure
as code ist total beknackter begriff entdecke den pioniergeist sind ja
ok mal schauen was war da vorn so will du bist bereit für eine zukunft die so
aufregend sein wird wie nie ist du bereit für eine welt voller neuer
digitaler möglichkeiten bereit für wohler ich kann mir so richtig
vorstellen wie das der wie das der voter vorn recruit typ erzählt so nach dem
motto bist du bereit für eine zukunft die so aufregend sein wird wie nie und
die leute die dann da vorsicht sagen ja bist du bereit für eine welt voller
neuer digitaler möglichkeiten bereit für wohler von kann ich mir richtig
vorstellen dann verbindet ein können mit besten aussichten als seo das ja
eigentlich eigentlich das richtige für mich ich meine ich mache das ja schon
paar ich wollte gerade sagen paar jahrzehnte das ist fast das ist aber
dann doch ein bisschen übertrieben so alt bin ich doch nicht aber ein jahrzehnt
mache sich schon also das da ich mache ich mache ja def ob schon zu zeiten
wo es nicht mal der ob sie ist dabei hast du das mww gelesen oh oje oje
da ist die anzeige raus
ja was soll das mww stehen männlich weiß wenig ahn keine ahnung
nein das soll ein d sein soll wahrscheinlich für männliche weiblich
diverse stehen sie haben sich ein bisschen vertan was auch immer männlich
weiblich was auch immer kann auch sein männlich weiß wichtig ok also was will
denn wo davon du willst die digitale welt verändern dann bist du in unserem
team gold richtig wir sind digitale weiterdenker und suchen kreative köpfe
und innovative ideen it visionäre und macher die der digitalen
telekommunikation den weg bereiten schnell und innovativ experten die
wissen dass geschwindigkeit zukunft bedeutet und die unseren kunden immer die
schnellste aller lösungen liefern
nimm die herausforderung an die deutschlandweit 40 millionen voter von
kunden in die digitale zukunft zu führen
ok das sind deine herausforderung du automatisierst generische
applikations was generischen applikations spezifische die pläume
und pipelines im im was im center of excellence
ok das habe ich noch nie gehört ehrlich gesagt aber gut du automatisierst
generische und applikationsspezifische die pläume und pipelines im center of
excellence aber kann das sein dass das gar nicht
rein gehört in diesen satz weil weil und ohne ohne würde der satz einen sinn
ergeben ich habe das noch nie gehört center of
ex ich habe das wirklich jt nicht jt jt ich habe ich habe das noch nie gehört
weiß nicht was das ist
es schert facility
immer noch keine ahnung was es ist
das ist ja was ist dann
jt jt erklärt was das ist ich habe wirklich keine ahnung das ist nicht mal gefakt
ich habe kein schimmer was center of excellence ist kontinuous integration
und deployment cd müsste müsste continuous delivery sein eigentlich
es ist nicht kontinuous deployments es heißt nicht kontinuous delivery ist
eigentlich unser it organisieren ok das passt für das passt für defops engineer
auf jeden fall schon mal ziemlich gut du definierst und konzipierst standards
für pipelines tools prozesse und umgebungen publik klauen passt auch
wunderbar zu defops engineer also es ist nicht so wie die zweite anzeige die wir
gelesen haben die die den admin wollten unten in project manager
ok nerbeer nice moment ich muss mal kurz ein bild adden zu meinem zu meinem tool
zwar diese domain sag wow sag ich hoffe das ist auch transparent will
speichern unter teufel desktop hinzufügen funktioniert ok also wenn
jetzt mal wieder was mit java angesagt das habe ich passende bild dazu
du übernimmst die vendor und domain übergreifende abstimmung von
strategischen deployment konzepte und architektur das ist auch sehr vage
formuliert das würde ich aber auch sagen passt zu der stelle
du berätst fachbereiche bei der einführung und nutzung von sie dass es
auch passen für der als defops engineer du koordinierst die reihungslose und
störungsfreie enterprise moment ist das enterprise enterprise can be to beat
end-to-end end-to-end logisch eigentlich logisch dass es end-to-end es klingt
auch viel logischer als enterprise enterprise end-to-end innerhalb von
großprojekten du koordinierst die reibungslose und störungsfreie end-to-end
implementierung von applikation innerhalb von großprojekten du
koordinierst die reibungslose und störungsfreie end-to-end implementieren
meinen die damit dass wenn in dem projekt mehrere applikationen entwickelt
werden dass man dann dafür sorgen soll dass die miteinander gescheit können
das ist das damit gemeint ansonsten fällt es mir gerade schwer mir dann
ob es ein reim drauf zu machen was mir der satz sagen soll
du bringst mit ein abgeschlosser schluss
da bin ich ja schon mal raus da bin ja schon mal aus vertiefte
kenntnisse in heterogenen betriebssystem und anbanken
eure kill unix also von datenbanken habe ich eigentlich nur rudimentär eine
ahnung also ich kann ein paar joints programmieren
ja ich kann prinzipiell kann ich ja ich bin aber kein dba mit linux kenne ich
mich ziemlich gut aus
gängige cloud architektur die nach dem was sie haben wollen auch mindestens acht
jahre berufserfahrung in der it sowie ich habe sogar über zehn jahre
erfahrung im deffops bereich also wenn ich da nicht senior deffops bin da weiß
ich auch nicht tiefes verständnis von hochkritischen
großvolumigen it system das kann man so sagen ist bei uns nicht viel anders
sehr gute englischkenntnisse in wort und schrift
ich glaube da wollen sie was auch immer das in für standard ist da wollen sie
wahrscheinlich was was ich nicht hinkriege also richtig richtig krassen
business small talk auf englisch den ich gebacken ich kann mich mit leuten auf
englisch verständigen die wissen was ich will und vor allem wenn es um
technische sachen geht ist das eh einfacher aber das da was auch immer b 2
ist das habe ich wahrscheinlich nicht ab 2 ist ab in die woche kann man sich
hinschreiben kann man sich hinschreiben
diese stelle kann in vollzeit oder vollzeit nahe teilzeit ausgut werden
der ist schon mal gut für mich weil ich will ja nicht vollzeit ich will ja
eigentlich nur 30 stunden ja moment aber das gab es ja gar nicht in
frankfurt ja dann fällt für mich eh schon mal ich schon mal raus was was
bieten sie attraktive vergütung und überdurchschnittlich zusatzleistung
betriebliche altersvorsorge umfassende weiterbildung individuelle fehlung
talentreflexible arbeitszeit modelle und home office das kann was gutes sein
das kann auch was schlechtes sein aktive unterstützung bei der kinderbetreuung
das ist gut pflege von angehörigen das ist auch gut vielfältige gesundheitsangebote
das ist auch gut internationale karriere schanzen austauschen
ja ok ich muss sagen so schlecht ist die wurde
vornanzeige gar nicht
glaube nicht dass sie genau mich suchen würden oder ich glaube nicht dass ich
sag mal umgedreht ich glaube nicht dass ich da richtig gut drauf passen würde
aber
oder je nachdem wo sie den schwerpunkt drauf legen würde ich da schon ziemlich
gut drauf passen aber es ist eh nicht in frankfurt nächstes in ach doch in
eschborn habe ich ja gar nicht gelesen ich dachte die
ganze zeit in düsseldorf sind die in eschborn ist kein ding nach eschborn ist
iets da bin ich bin ich zwanzig minuten da oder so
ohne studium kann studium kein job da das ist die frage ich meine die schreiben
das zwar hier ob das wirklich anforderung ist wenn man schon quasi 15
ab 15 jahre erfahrung in dem gebiet hat ist wahrscheinlich davon abhängig wie
sie das sehen ja
also wenn ich jemand wissen wollen der weiß wovor also jemand haben wollen der
weiß wovor er spricht der defops schon gemacht habe zu zeiten wo das ganze
nicht mal defops hieß dann werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht so viele finden die
das schon so lange machen
ja sehe ich nämlich auch so denn ich deswegen ich glaube da schreiben die
einfach nur mal so als hürde rein falls jemand sagt ja ich habe jetzt fertig
studiert und kennen mich voll gut aus aber ich meine hey sie schreiben senior
das heißt auf jeden fall du bist nicht frisch fertig mit irgendwas und sie
schreiben auch hier acht jahre und acht jahre ist schon sehr senior
normalerweise würde ich sagen du kannst du kannst normalerweise nach nach drei
jahren kannst du da schon als senior durchgehen je nach dem wie und wo und
was aber acht jahre ist schon eine ordentliche
geschichte ist schon lange lange anforderung mindestens acht jahre
ja bei mir ist noch länger aber
ja also ich finde ich die anzeige gar nicht so schlecht ich glaube ich hatte ich
hätte kein großartigen bock auf voter phone jetzt um ehrlich zu sein aber
mein wenn das wenn das drumherum passen würde also ich muss sagen ich habe mir
jetzt schlimmeres vorgestellt nachdem man sehr wohl davon als anbieter so
kennt ich glaube ich weiß sogar wo das ist
falls das das in frankfurt ist dann weiß ich glaube ich wo das ist
ich weiß wo das ist nicht shopping
ach nee doch nicht dann ist das düsseldorf
nee das weiß ich nicht wo das ist aber lass mal gucken das ist da komme ich
locker hin das ist da bin ich in einer halben stunde morgens da aber 35 40
minuten bin ich morgens da mein aktuell ist mein arbeitsweg halt von hier drüben
quasi zum südbahnhof das südbahnhof ist da unten
da da fahre ich aktuell morgens immerhin so von hier drüben hierher dann
laufe ich hier hoch zeigt jetzt nicht so genau
dann würde ich einfach zum hauptbahnhof fahren also ich habe ich jetzt bei den
bewerben würde ich sage ich überlege nur gerade mal da würde ich einfach hier
hochfahren zum hauptbahnhof und fahre ich mit der s-bahn dahin das dürfte das
dürfte ziemlich easy as a f**ke sein ja okay machen wir in einem der
nächsten streams noch mal machen wir noch mal weiter
ich würde sagen wir können uns ab und zu mal so zwei drei stellen anzeigen
schon mal gönnen face league genau über google über über google google
earth face league das hat litt hat quasi durchs fenster
gezoomt ich muss mal kurz licht anmachen zu dunkel
genau licht dass ich mich besser in google map spiegeln
ok knäbchen was mir an exklaut nicht so gut gefallen hat
es sind eigentlich sind es kleinigkeiten allerdings ich finde recht bedeutende
recht bedeutende kleinigkeiten erstens hatte ich mal probleme mit dem
sink da haben dateien konfliktet und ich habe nicht gecheckt warum ich habe
nicht parallel editiert oder so oder es waren mindestens mal fünf minuten
dazwischen und der konflikt ließ ich auch nicht so ordentlich ordentlich
lösen irgendwie es war sehr merkwürdig was daraus geführt hat dass der eine der
die eine seite irgendwie ob keine dateien mal richtig geschrieben hat ganz
merkwürdig also ich mein dateien zynk ist ist eines der hauptaufgaben von
von exklaut wir müssen uns über die change logs angucken was da so passiert
ist ich würde sagen wir machen die richtige
next cloud installation machen wir dann morgen oder mal gucken wie lange was
heute auch noch ich habe ja eigentlich zeit wie heißt
wie heißt noch mal das backup tool was du benutzt borg backup dann hatte ich
noch das problem mit next cloud das auch eine sache die ich mir angucken wollte
dass das tool die die notizen app kompletter crap gewesen ist da hat
nicht mehr die suche funktioniert und wozu brauchst du eine notiz app wo die
suche nicht funktioniert ist mobil kein problem da hast du da hast du lokale
apps und auf dem desktop kannst du theoretisch auch lokale apps haben aber
wenn es eine web app für notizen gibt und die keine suche hat ist schon
bescheuert die to do app war auch müll die hatte auch keine richtige suche
und wahrscheinlich ein paar kleinigkeiten ich glaube ich habe aktuell noch
next cloud 14 drauf nee habe ich nicht ich habe next cloud wann kam 14 raus
ich muss mal kurz gucken was ich für eine für eine next cloud version bei mir
aktuell habe weiß die ip gar nicht na geil muss ich mal kurz nachgucken
settings
habe ich doch richtig gemacht eigentlich hier slash next cloud und ich habe
irgendwie englische tastatur belegung wieder mal kurz gucken was ich für eine
version habe
ok ich habe die next cloud version das sieht man auch bestimmt im admin
interface irgendwo 13 habe ich next cloud 13 habe ich noch also da hat sich sehr
viel getan dazwischen
was ist der vorteil von next cloud gegenüber sagen wir mal einem samba
server dass sie die dateien zünden kann samba server ist ja das ist ja also
eigentlich ist ist ist dateien zünkt ja der komplette das komplette gegenteil von
dem samba server samba server ist zentral wo man drauf zugreift und in
sync von dateien heißt sie liegen letztendlich auch auf unterschiedlichen
systemen dann ja genau und du hast eine history was sich geändert hat und wer
was geändert so das ist nicht so wichtig aber im falle des samba servers wenn
der samba server im arsch sind die dateien im arsch hast du deine dateien
gesüngt auf drei rechnern sind die halt auf drei rechner noch da und man
benutzt das eigentlich hauptsächlich für sachen die relativ klein sind also
für irgendwelche notizen oder sonst was oder aber was auch beliebt ist um
fotos die man gemacht hat direkt direkt in einem foto album zu sünden oder so
was
ist ein bisschen anders gelagert als ein zentraler fileserver und natürlich ich
kann auf meinem smartphone beispielsweise notizen machen fotos machen
kontakte hinzufügen du schreibe und und das dann zu meinem server sünden und
alle anderen geräte sehens entweder habe ich den zugang von außen zu meinem
server dass ich direkt sünden kann oder aber mein smartphone sünd einfach dann
wenn ich daheim bin und ins wlan gehe automatisch es ist es ist halt auch
irgendwie eine komfort sache ok was habe ich gesagt ich habe gesagt ich habe
nextcloud 13 das heißt da gucken wir doch mal was da alles so gekommen ist mit
nextcloud 14
nextcloud 14 wir gucken uns die zusammenfassung an
wir gucken uns die zusammenfassung an
ach guck mal japan wikipedia eine schöne übersicht das ist ja nice also bei 14 ist
dazugekommen im detail natürlich noch viel weiter viel mehr verbesserung zwei
faktor authentifizierung kam dazu video verifizierung des empfängers
nextcloud talk ok wusste ich gar nicht dass sie irgendwie so in so eine so ein
als auf discord machen oder so weitere neuerung prüfung aller installierten
apps auf kompatibilität ok die bedienung wurde überarbeitet das ist auch ganz
gut ein dunkles design or das ist nice das ist da freue ich mich dass das
nextcloud design hat mir ehrlich gesagt nie so gut gefallen das war jetzt das
blau auf weiß warum update ist du nicht weil ich schlechte erfahrungen mit
nextcloud updates gemacht habe und weil es auf der falschen kiste läuft in dem
fall ist es einfacher neu zu installieren und die daten rüber zu ziehen
anstatt quasi die 13 installation zu upgraden umzuziehen oder umzuziehen und
zu upgraden viele verbesserungen für barriere freies arbeit am komputer das
das ist immer gut ich brauch es zwar nicht aber ich finde es immer gut wenn
software oder wenn wenn wenn wenn hersteller darauf achten dass ihre
produkte auch von leuten benutzt werden können die vielleicht schlechter sehen
oder andere anarbeitlich beeinträchtigt sind notizen zu freigaben teilen von
der teilen via nextcloud talk notizen zu freigaben
also zu shares ok zwei fakte authentifizierung durchbar klingt ganz
klingt ganz gut
sicher als ende zu ende verschlüsselung das ist cool das ist nice das ist
wirklich nice man müsste sich mal man müsste sich mal angucken wie das
implementiert ist aber das ist richtig gut weil ich kann natürlich auf dem
server mein laufwerk wo meine nextcloud sachen drauf legen
achso ich bin geht zur version 13 das hat meine version schon aber trotzdem ist
das gut trotzdem ist ich sehe es auch ich habe ich
falsche richtung ja ich habe es gesehen aber trotzdem ist das gut weil ich kann
zwar die die platte verschlüsseln wo mein nextcloud drauf liegt aber wenn ich
dateien zünke zum beispiel auf mein auf mein iphone oder auf in den android
tablet oder sowas und die liegen da unverschlüsselt drauf rum sind die
dateien ja auch bringt mir nichts wenn die auf dem server verschlüssel liegen
das muss ich mir auf jeden fall mal genau angucken
ok nextcloud 15 neue social app unter anderem mastadon
mastadon das ist den mammut oder ist mastadon nicht in mammut mit dem
kommunikationsprotokoll activity pub social app naja so viele leute verwenden
mein nextcloud nicht meine mutter verwendet nextcloud und ich verwende meine nextcloud
zwei leute verwenden meine nextcloud und der mastadon macht teilweise offsite
backups drauf das war es
ja unter clocks hd verwenden mein nextcloud gut ist gut dass du mir das
mal sagst wenigstens hast du hast du besondere wünsche zu den zeiten wann ich
die wann ich das upgraden darf wann brauchst du es nicht ok die ladezeiten
der internetseite und verbessert das ist immer gut mach einfach tiefere
integration von collabora online mit chatfunktion das ist cool
khaloba khalo ach du scheiße ich kann sich aussprechen ist auch egal wie es
heißt das ist open office mit oder libre office mit ein bisschen google
documents flair also es ist liebe office liebe office wo
leute quasi zusammen editieren können eigentlich eine coole geschichte wenn man
es braucht ok und
ach unterstützt bis ok ich bin doof manchmal ich dachte was wollen sie mit
im april 2020 sagen es wird unterstützt bis april 2020 ok und in nextcloud
kam kam erst kam erst vor drei monaten raus also was gibt es dafür neuerungen
neue access control lists können ältere proprietäre falls aber ersetzen
ok muss ich mir angucken autentifizierung erkennung von
verdächtigen einfach so eine snow wow jetzt wird aber advanced jetzt sperrt
man nicht einfach nach fünf nach fünf unzulässigen login versuchen einfach die
ip jetzt erkennt man verdächtige anmelde gar aktivitäten mit einem
neuronalen netzwerk ford big brain
funktionen projekte die benutzer können ihre arbeit organisieren indem sie
verschiedene ressourcen zu projekten zusammen ach das ist cool das ist cool
das wirklich nice die man konnte glaube ich bisher schon ordner machen aber das
war nicht so schön das ist wirklich ganz cool da kann ein
projekt anlegen zum beispiel hier irgendwie was weiß ich wenn ich was für
die arbeit mache von daheim könnte ich mir das beispielsweise könnte mir
kalender anlegen wo ich beeintrage ok so lange hast du gearbeitet oder ein paar
ressourcen also es ist das schließt sich ganz cool nextcloud talk 6.0 und wenn ich
wahrscheinlich nicht verwenden
interessant ist das auf jeden fall was die da so getrieben haben
sag mal ist es immer die gleiche musik seit drei stunden ist es nicht
max was sagst du eigentlich zu office 365 für schulen das kam ja in der letzten
woche mal wieder hoch
ich weiß nicht ob man an der schule office 365 brauche
wozu brauche man eine schule office 365 was macht man da so toll ist in office
dass man office 365 braucht dass man überhaupt in office braucht bin in der
meinung in der regel das was in der schule macht wird wahrscheinlich den
texteditor reichen ein bisschen markt und drauf und gut ist
so das wird schon auf linux rüber habe ich meinen raspberry von gestern noch an
ne habe ich nicht an der hängt hier rum der hängt hier rum und ist nicht mehr am
strom angeschlossen deswegen kann er auch nicht mehr an sein
wo ich mal anmachen jetzt er wieder an
ich meine wenn es wenn man an der schule in office unbedingt braucht warum nicht
office 365 ich meine ich persönlich wüsste ja ich verwende überhaupt keine
office programe und ich bin da an sich das einzige office programe was da sein
berechtigung was eine da sein berechtigung hat ist excel oder halt
tabellenkalkulation
weil sie auch letztens im stream quasi die die häufigste programmier sprache
die die die programmier sprache die die meisten leute können ist excel
ms project da wird zwar zeit hierfür ms project es gibt ja kaum was
schlimmeres ich habe mit ms project gantia kram für
meine abschlussprüfung gemacht das war ganz das war ganz schlimm
allerdings ist für mich so die standard office die standard office
programe sind für mich tabellenkalkulation präsentationsprogramm
textverarbeitung das zeug war laut ist ganz gut ja
wobei ich an war naught halt blöd finde also war naught ist so ein ding alles oder
nichts du musst wenn du war naught verwendet
muss du theoretisch war naught auch überall verwenden weil es ist halt kein
plaintext mehr also ich bin schon dafür dass man an der schule mal gezeigt
krieg wie eine textverarbeitung funktioniert oder oder wie eine
tabellenkalkulation funktioniert aber ganz ehrlich es es soll es sollte sich
nicht so sehr auf microsoft eigenheiten erstrecken man sollte den leuten
beibringen wie man den brief schreibt und das halt mal in der tabellenkalkulation
machen das kann auch meinetwegen wird sein allerdings man sollte die die
schüler heute nicht unterschätzen die sind doch nicht blöd wenn du den
zeigst wie man einen brief schreiben soll denken die sich erst mal lol alter
warum soll ich den brief schreiben sowas ist ja hier 2019 aber vielleicht müssen
ja mal in einem amt einen brief schreiben oder sonst was
nein die sind nicht blöd in der richtung sind die nicht blöd ich ich
halte leute ich halte in der regel default mäßig eigentlich jeden für
blöd aber ich halte nicht die leute bei uns in der schule für zu blöd wenn die
wissen wie man eine textverarbeitung bedient traue ich denen zu dass sie das
ohne probleme in allen anderen text aber in allen anderen textverarbeitung auch
hinbekommen wenn die schon mal den brief geschrieben haben in wird schaffen
die das auch ohne probleme den brief in libre office zu schreiben oder den brief
in wordpad zu schreiben und ein brief in diesem komischen china office zu
schreiben ich habe jetzt vergessen wie es wie heißt das china office noch mal
irgendwie king king soft office oder so
ist das überhaupt das china office ja das ist jetzt der china office ist das
oder was auch immer also wenn wenn leute die heute in der schule sind wenn die
eins können dann ist es gelernte sachen auf technischer
ebene zu zu zu transferieren zwischen programm
das können die das war jeden tag das juckt heute keinen mehr ob der ab oder c
hast für irgendwas wenn wenn wenn man eines der art kann dann kann man die
andere auch
ich kann nur ich weiß nicht ich glaube da unterschätzt den die leute
der blog watcher sagt ich glaube echt heute haben schüler weniger andere von
pc als vor zehn jahren zwar von zeitang gut desktop pc ist ja nicht mehr der
heiße schitt und selbst damals kannte sich nur eine ganz beschränkte gruppe
wirklich gut mit pc aus ja
du unterschätzt nicht ok wenn ihr das sagt dann sagt aber nicht ich habe die
ich habe die schüler von heute schlecht gemacht oder so ich bin dann auch der
das hier am optimistischen sieht allerdings sollte es die aufgabe in der
schule sein dass wir die leuten eben beibringen nicht etwa so funktioniert
microsoft word sondern so schreibt man einen brief und so macht man das in der
textverarbeitung und wenn man das in einer textverarbeitung kann und nicht
komplett beschränkt ist kann man das in jeder anderen textverarbeitung aus
auch
nee nicht in slackgruppen microsoft teams ist doch jetzt angesagt und es
also eines eines der hauptargumente die ja immer gebracht wird wenn wenn
microsoft sachen den kindern oder den leuten der schule beigebracht wird ist
ja die industrie würde das verlangen es ist nicht unbedingt zumindest ist das
meine sicht der dinge ja es ist nicht unbedingt die aufgabe den schülern an
der schule nur das beizubringen was die industrie haben will oder was die
industrie sich wünscht es ist wichtig dass man den leuten das prinzipiell
erklärt ja und dass sie wissen wie ein brief aussieht zum beispiel ja und die
sache wie das jeweilige unternehmen dann diesen brief in software umgesetzt
haben will das sollen sie gefällig den leuten selbst erklären
es geht darum dass du weißt wie es geht nicht dass du weißt was du in wörth
klicken musst mal ganz davon abgesehen ist auch total bescheuert
stellt euch mal vor irgendjemand ist jetzt in der keine ahnung der sechsten
klasse und die lernen jetzt wie man in wörth einen brief schreibt
ich glaube ich glaube doch nicht ernsthaft dass wenn der typ mal arbeiten
geht oder oder oder wenn die mal arbeiten geht dass dann wört noch so aussieht
wie damals in der schule wörth sieht alle drei jahre anders aus
zumindest anders genug dass es nicht mal funktioniert
ja genau wenn du so gleich verschrecken willst wir haben auch genug azubis die
vornixen plan haben aber ob das besser wird wenn man ihn jetzt quasi zeigt wo
man in wörth klicken muss wage ich zu bezweifeln
ja sei du sehe ich genauso den text editor mit markdown ist eigentlich das
beste was du machen kannst da konzentrierst du dich aufs wesentliche
nämlich wie man den ordentlichen text schreibt wie man das verständlich
macht wie man das wie man das dann formatiert ist nebensache und das ist
halt den markdown auch super easy du machst dann machst du eine raute davor
hast du eine überschrift macht zwei rauten davor ist eine kleinere überschrift
machst du machst ein minus davor hast eine liste den stink normaler text editor mit
markdown wäre wahrscheinlich echt das beste weil das lenkt dann auch nicht vom
wesentlichen ab sondern einfach über den mist tippt
ich kann es verstehen dass schulen also jetzt zum thema was gamer 329 sagt ich
verstehe zum teil schon dass schulen das schulen office und windows verwenden das
liegt nämlich daran weil wir nicht auf der höhe der zeit sind was ausstattung
und und kenntnisse der leute anbelangt dass es oft genug noch so ist dass sich
in der schule lehre ehrenamtlich um die technik kümmern und die meisten lehrer
schlicht ergreifen sich wenn überhaupt mit office und windows aus kennen
das ist einfach und da wird sich wahrscheinlich auch nichts dran ändern
linux auf dem desktop können wir vergessen also das hat sich die ist die
letzten 15 jahre nichts passiert und wird die nächsten zehn jahre auch nichts
mehr passieren es sei denn und ist das ist das einzige was was ich mir
vorstellen könnte dass es aus der gaming richtung kommt das ist das einzige was
wir vorstellen könnte wenn das werf und und wenn das walve und irgendwie wenn da
sich die die sterne im passenden winkel ausrichten dass der erfolg von linux
auf so nur nach 15 rechner tatsächlich über die gaming seite kommen wird wenn
überhaupt
weil wenn einer auf den microsoft mist keinen bock kann dann ist es walwe die
haben da die geht das auf und sagt volvo ja
das ist das einzige was ich mir vorstellen kann aber ich glaube nicht
dran und also wo ich wo ich wo ich komplett den glauben in die linux
entwickler quasi nicht in die linux entwickler das stimmt nicht die können
entwickler können dafür nämlich nix die also wo ich da wo ich da ein bisschen so
den glauben drin verloren hat ist dass man auf die reihe kriegt dass man oder
dass das die die teams die sich da hauptsächlich um die großen open source
projekte kümmern dass das ist die auf die reihe kriegen wirklich anwendung zu
stricken bis auf ein paar ausnahmen die die leute dazu bringen um zu steigen und
zu benutzen
die desktop landschaft unter linux ist logste kein hintermond mit hervor
vergleiche es mal mit einem meck es gibt ein paar ausnahmen es gibt so
elementary us das sieht ganz hübsch aus aber auch nur mit den standard anwendungen
das gute und schlechte zugleich unter linux ist halt einfach dass es wild wuchs
ist das ist nicht gut und nicht schlecht das ist einfach die art und weise von
und von unterschiedlichen projekten die nicht miteinander zu tun haben und nicht
miteinander koordiniert werden das das ist einfach so das ist gut und
schlecht gleichermaßen es ist gut das bringt gute software hervor für
technisch basierte nutzer das bringt vielfältige software hervor das bringt
auch nischen software hervor die man sonst teuer kaufen müsste ja was es
halt nicht hervorbringt ist was gesamtheitlich ist einheitliches dann
muss schon jemand anrücken wie google und android machen
da geht das auch aber android also ich bin immer noch der ansicht wenn man
android mit ios vergleicht erkennt man immer noch dass da na gut das hat mit
linux wenig zu tun das ist eher die google philosophie die
heute mal so machen und morgen mal so und dann ihre eigenen anwendungen nicht
mehr supporten wollen aber ich glaube linux wird sich nie durchsetzen weil
weil es dort die anwendungen die killer anwendungen gibt die sonst nirgendswo
gibt für den normalen anwender das glaube ich einfach nicht gibt wird es
auch nicht geben dass das hat sich ja schon in allen
anderen bereichen hat sich das ja schon durchgesetzt
er auf jedem toaster ist heute linux drauf auf jedem fernseh ist heute linux
drauf auf den auf den ticket automaten auf den auf den ticket automaten ist ein
raspberry pi drinnen mit linux linux ist überall linux ist aber halt nicht auf
dem casual desktop und der casual desktop ist eh am aussterben
den casual desktop gibt es kaum noch es gibt das casual tablet das casual
smartphone und es gibt den gaming rechner mit winners drauf das heißt das
einzige wo ich mir wirklich vorstellen könnte könnte es eigentlich eins zu
eins nehmen und in video packen oder das wird wahrscheinlich auch gut für
youtube eignen das einzige wo ich mir wirklich vorstellen
könnte dass ich dass ich linux breit noch mal durchsetzen würde auf den
rechnern die die leute daheim stehen haben ist über die gaming-schiene ja aber
das ist das das ist das einzige und in technischen technischen sachen hat
sich ja schon durchgesetzt ich habe auf der arbeit auch linux laptop
leute die im netzwerkbereich arbeit haben auch linux ganz klar
ja leute die anwendung entwickeln web anwendung irgendwelche server software
ist egal leute die programmieren die haben sau oft auch linux als
arbeitsumgebung das sei denn sie werden irgendwie gezwungen windows zu verwenden
überall da ist linux ja schon angekommen das ist aber halt nicht der
sagen wir der der casual noob rechner daheim den vielleicht noch irgendwie
einer da stehen hat weil er regelmäßig mal seine lottozahler nachgucken will
oder e-mails schreiben will oder weil die oma nachgucken will wer ihre
freundin auf facebook geschrieben hat da wird es auch nie linux drauf geben
zumindest nicht breit
ja so viel zu diesem thema
ja die rmv ticket automaten laufen auch auf linux
weiß gar nicht ob sie da offiziell jemals was zu gesagt haben ja die neun
rmv ticket automaten laufen nach raspberry pi ich weiß
ja das siehst du wenn die dinger manchmal buten siehst du bei unseren
ticket automaten raspberry logo und linux buten ich bin also nicht der
einzige der das schon gesehen hat
wer sowas ist das schon angekommen
in manchen fällen funktioniert das aber das funktioniert dann aber auch nur
wenn die leute jemand technisch basierten daheim haben der ihm das
installiert und vielleicht auch die ein oder anderen sachen erzählen kann wo es
halt niemals funktionieren wird ist wie gesagt der der casual benutzer der
daheim sitzt sich seine tune-up tools installiert ab und zu mal irgendwie auf
steam was kauft was spielt facebook guckt mal ein paar fotos bearbeitet
irgendwie paar rote augeneffekte macht sie versuchen ja ab und zu mal auf
linux umzusteigen scheitern aber einfach daran weil sie weil sie mit der
erwartung dran gehen dass das quasi ein besseres windows wäre ist halt nicht so
und an an so an so nur freundlich freundlicher standard software fehlt
halt unter linux auch block watcher klar warum nicht so raspberry pi ist super
so ein ticket automat
gut chat
ja
um deswegen wie gesagt ich glaube wenn schon kommt das kommt das über die
gaming gaming ecke
1903 gesehen 1903
ich persönlich habe das kotzen das ist das ist das neueste windows hier was ich
was ich drauf habe das einzige was mir aufgefallen ist dass das startmenü jetzt
so komisch ist also wenn ich jetzt hier suche so irgendwie hallo dann ist das
startmenü irgendwie so hier da das aber das einzige was mir aufgefallen ist am
neuen windows design ansonsten finde ich sieht das genauso aus wie vorher
oder was meinste immer 329
ja war not ich finde war auch gut das einzige problem ist halt wie ich schon
gesagt habe dass du war not all in all in muss weißte wenn du war not verwendet
überall ist ein bisschen so wie ever not da ist halt kein plan text mehr da du
musst dann wo auch überall verwenden es gibt kein gescheit in linux klein es
gibt es gibt oder korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch liege ja es gibt einen web
kleint in one node web kleint offiz 365 unter linux aber ansonsten ist die suche
immer noch braun weiß ich verwendet die suche unter windows nicht hast du
eigentlich noch kontakt zu docker ganz selten was aber nicht an ihm liegt
von mir weil ich ja voller spaß bin und mich irgendwie nicht melde bei den
leuten
was hältst du von gott galaxy du meinst diesem neuen du meinst das neue was alle
anderen kleins irgendwie integrieren soll finde ich ist eine gute idee habe ich
habe neu ausprobiert
kommt mal der back ist wieder da
der back ist wieder da
oder liegt der back an den e-mails das kann aber natürlich auch sein
nee ich habe echt da ich habe da den back drinnen warum hast du immer eine
eins in die urleiste hast du tix da gibt es ein kommando für machen wir ausrufe
zeichnen 1 wird das erklärt also ja ich habe sie nicht mehr alle in der
erbrichtung ich mache immer einsen und kopier die dann ausrufe zeichnen 1 1
ausgeschrieben
w pista
wir wir wir tun im
Ah nice Moni-Tabakus sehe ich ja jetzt erst.
Ach ne eigene Firma etwa bloß hab ich doch schon.
Stimmt wollte ich ja.
Hast du einen L-Pick nein ich hab keinen L-Pick.
Das ist so eine Linux Zertifizierung.
Wenn du mal richtige Abenteuer erleben willst musst du die IT Stellanzeigen bei VW angucken.
Das machen wir das nächste Mal.
Der Blur-Effekt der Anmeldemasker kann sein.
Also ist mir so ein großer Unterschied gar nicht aufgefallen im letzten Windows Update.
Wolltest du nicht irgendwas wegen Discord zeigen?
Nö wir haben jetzt einen Discord.
Machen wir Ausrufezeichen Discord.
Wir haben jetzt einen Discord.
Wir haben jetzt einen Max-FPS-Wupplors-Discord.
Da ist er.
Wir haben es absichtlich übersichtlich gehalten.
Das da unten seht ihr alles gar nicht.
Es gibt einen Channel für Programmiergeschichten, einen Channel für Heimautomatisierung und
wenn irgendjemand Hilfe bei irgendwas braucht.
Wir haben Themenvorschläge für Videos und Streams.
Ankündigungen von mir und Allgemeines wo man alles mögliche Zeug beschwätzen kann wo
man Bock drauf hat.
Es gibt auch keine Sachen die man nicht besprechen darf es sei denn ich stelle mal irgendwann
fest Leute schreiben sich da komische Dinge dann muss ich mir was überlegen.
Achso und ein Looky for Clubs Chat für Games also wir haben es sehr übersichtlich gehalten.
Ja und wie gesagt ich bin auch drauf.
Guck mal hier sind sie schon wieder am Progres diskutieren oder wenn ihr eine Programmierhilfe
braucht.
Ja.
Also wenn ihr wollt Ausrufezeichen Discord dann gibt es den Invitelink.
Komische Dinge passieren jetzt schon im Weeb-Channel im Weeb-Channel dürfen meinetwegen komische
Dinge passieren.
Da guckt das die Baro rein der sorgt dafür dass es nicht gar so komisch ist oder nicht
illegal komisch wird und ansonsten könnt ihr da machen was ihr wollt.
Die
Mit der stats anzeige mit den mit den dark themes mit einem ordentlichen terminal mit einer ordentlichen schönen schrift art
Ja lässt sich einfach viel schöner
Viel schöner custom isen ja auch ordentliches farbschema und also lässt sich einfach viel schöner custom isen wie die windows
Was ist das für eine i3 bar das ist i3 status rust heißt das glaube ich
I3 status rust ja wir können übrigens mal einen
Paket update machen
Bei der gelegenheit
Wurde heute bett company drei diskutiert
Ne weil da gab es nicht als du dir gibt es nicht allzu viel zu diskutieren
Weil es gibt ja noch nichts großartiges drüber neues
Außer dass es halt eben wahrscheinlich als 2020 mit der ps5 kommt aber da müssen wir abwarten
Oh guck mal gibt es sogar update von
Hast du dir mal das windows subsystem für linux angeschaut und wenn ja was hältst du davon ich finde es ich finde es vom ansatz her ziemlich gut
Es hat halt noch einige einschränkungen
Zum beispiel kannst du keine sachen mountain und sowas und die performance lässt sich auch nicht so gut auswählen
Da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher ob das an wsl legt oder ob das an dem an dem microsoft terminal legt
und das zusammenspiel zwischen
Windows programm und linux programm ist natürlich auch nicht so gut wird es wahrscheinlich nie sein ja also es es geht zum beispiel nicht ohne weiteres dass ich
In der shell was von dem linux kommando zu einem
Windows kommando pipe oder so. Ja
Ich bin auch mal auf WSL 2 gespannt.
Ich schreibe mir das auf, wir basteln demnächst wirklich mal eine Qt-Anwendung, also keine
Qt-Chat-Anwendung, sondern eine Qt-Anwendung.
Was Simples und gucken mal, ob das gut funktioniert, da können sich die ganzen C++ Leute freuen.
Hast du Borg in WSL getestet, ja funktioniert, funktioniert.
Was machen das, Paket-Update, oh Paket-Update ist fertig, oh guck mal sogar die neuen iPhone
Drivers sind mit drauf.
Übrigens sehr praktisch hier, warum man immer das iDevice Installer heißt, das ist eigentlich
ein Driver, mit dem man sein iPhone mounten kann auf Linux, also braucht man kein iTunes
und Gedöns.
Einfach iPhone mounten und man kann auf alles zugreifen, auf Bilder, auf gespeicherte Notizen
von Anwendungen und sowas, sehr praktisch.
Was hältst du von Minimalist-Distros wie Arch oder Gentoo, beziehungsweise Minimalist-Software
wie MPD oder die ganzen Ziel-Eidinger, ja verwende ich ja auch, ich finde das gut,
ich finde das gut, wenn sich die Sachen auswesentlich konzentrieren, manchmal darf es halt auch
ruhig mal ein bisschen ausgefallener sein, ja also wenn es zum Beispiel eine To-Do-Notiz
sonst was Programm ist, klingt erstmal super simpel, darf aber ruhig schon ein paar ordentliche
Funktionen haben.
Gibt es leider zu wenig gute, eigentlich gerade kein gutes, na klar braucht man ein
extra Driver für, was meinst du, wie du sonst ein iPhone mounten willst.
Also ich meine, du kannst das öffnen als USB-Gerät, das ist kein Problem, aber wenn
du jetzt beispielsweise auf deine Notizanwendung zugreifen willst, dann geht das nur, wenn
du das als mit Apple spezifischen Sachen mountest, weil das kannst du ja sonst auch nicht sehen
im Explorer oder so.
Also, es ist 22 Uhr Leute, ich bleib noch kurz on, also ich seh nicht, ob ich jetzt
in off gehe, die Nextcloud Installation machen wir morgen, das hat heute nicht ganz hingehauen,
wir waren heute mit anderen Dingern beschäftigt, so Max SideTrack Store wieder am Start, drei
Stunden, aber ich würd sagen, nichtsdestotrotz waren wir heute relativ produktiv mit dem,
was wir gemacht haben, also wir haben eigentlich was gemacht.
Also das mit den Stellenanzeigen, wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr das öfters machen, ich
glaub das ist ne ganz gute Sache, die man immer so zur Belustigung einstreuen kann,
ab und zu mal und sich angucken, was sich die Leute da wieder ausgedacht haben, und ihr
wollt Q-Chat, ja.
Das ist viel besser platziert da unten oder?
Das muss ich auch mal in meinem Tool updaten, dass man Positionen pro Bild speichern kann
und nicht nur global, der Chat verdeckt, oh, Chat verdeckt, das geht ja gar nicht, aber
das ist Q-Chat, Q-Chat kann eigentlich nix verdecken, haben wir noch was, also wie gesagt
haben wir noch was, also wenn ihr noch was wissen wollt oder wenn ihr noch was ist, haut's
raus in Chat, ich bin auch kurz da, na docker install, docker nextcloud install war auch
sowas, was ich nicht gemacht habe, weil sie damals Probleme mit Updates hatten, und grade
docker lustigerweise ja unter anderem die easieste Plattform ist, was zu updaten schlechthin.
Darf ich mit schlafen kommen, das kommt drauf an, wenn du ein Hottes Gaming Grill bist,
18 plus, dann können wir uns da noch mal drüber unterhalten, wobei 18 plus, sagen wir mal,
sagen wir mal 25 plus, achso, na dann, aber da darf ich jetzt ja nix dagegen sagen, weil
sonst ist die Anzeige wieder raus, ja Busfahrer überzeugt, ja, der Sebaro, beim Sebaro ist
16, ok, der ist selber, der ist selber nicht so alt, bis bald 21, ja ne, dann nicht, dann
ist Monka Toss angesagt, warum hab ich eigentlich keinen Monka Toss bei mir im, was, Moment,
es gibt Nextcloud, hab ich im Nextcloud schon dabei, ach ne, ja ne, dass der Desktop kleint,
Moment, Monka Toss, hat jemand ein schönes, transparentes, hochauflösendes Monka Toss
Build, das da, das ist zu klein, das ist zu klein, Monka, Monka Toss, ok, ok, ok, ok,
naja, besser als nix, oder, hab ich überhaupt, ich hab Monka Toss noch nicht mal aktuell
aktiviert im Chat, ok, es gibt kein Nextcloud bei denen, dumme Frage, wieso geht Ctrl C
und Ctrl V im Terminal nicht, weil die schon anders belegt sind, weil Ctrl C ist den aktuell
laufenden Befehl abbrechen und Ctrl V ist glaube ich standardmäßig nichts, aber Ctrl
C ist Befehl abbrechen, du musst, du musst, du kannst machen, Ctrl Shift C und Ctrl Shift
V, ja wir brauchen es auch für Raspian, Nextcloud, warum mach ich das jetzt eigentlich doch,
das wollte ich doch erst morgen machen, da strobelt Stefan, naja, blablabla, ja gut,
das ist immer noch das klassische Tar runterladen und nach WWHTML, entpacken, wir machen das
mit SQLite zum testen, wir brauchen keine MariaDB oder sonst was, das gefällt im Chat,
huge Chat, copy link location, ah WWHTML, achso, nicht da, ja dann installen wir mal
ein nginx, was hältst du eigentlich von Postgres beste beste, open source Datenbank, Postgres
beste, alter lan, wallah, Postgres beste, ne, aber ohne scheiß, Postgres beste Datenbank,
die es open source mäßig so gibt, relationale Datenbank, achso, wir könnten vielleicht mal
WireGuard wieder deinstallieren, andererseits juckt es auch nicht, wenn es an ist, ne, ne,
das machen wir mal mal, das machen wir mal mal mit nextcloud, dauert sonst zu lang, schon
mal von ArangoDB gehört, nope, es gibt mittlerweile so viele NoSQL Datenbanken, es war gerade
klar, dass es eine NoSQL Datenbank ist, ey, was sonst, habe ich aber nix von gehört, hast
du eine Meinung zu OpenSSL, ja ohne gehts nicht, warum auf dem Rest, zum testen, ja,
zum testen, ich könnte es mir auch in einem Containerlokal installieren, aber den Raspberry
haben wir eh noch hier dran von gestern, ich muss den übrigens, muss das doch noch mal
starten und den Raspberry ordentlich runterfahren, weil wenn Raspberries eins nicht mögen, dann
müssen wir einfach Strom rausziehen, dann dürfen wir morgen gleich die SD-Karte neu
machen, Power off, bam, jetzt können wir die VM ausschalten, übrigens ich muss euch jetzt
noch mal hier was loswerden an den cute chat, ich finde das echt toll, wie viele Leute
immer am Start sind, ohne dass ich das irgendwo ankündige oder sonst was und wie viele Leute
sich hier für so Technik-Krams tatsächlich interessieren, hier ist auch ein großer Anteil
an, oder ein hoher Anteil an Leuten, die sich tatsächlich auskennen mit dem einen oder
anderen Thema, das ist sehr nice, ich würde sagen, das ist einzigartig in Deutschland,
das gibt es gefühlt sonst nirgendswo, ich will nicht sagen, dass es sonst keine Technik-Sachen
gibt, aber wo wirklich ein hoher Anteil an Leuten ist, die sich auskennen, das gibt
es eigentlich so gut wie nirgendswo, ja Quinn gibt es immer, ist auch nicht schlimm, vielleicht
wird es dir interessiert, ich meine vielleicht lernst du ja was, das wäre natürlich ganz
besonders toll noch, aber du bist natürlich jederzeit auch als ahnungsloser willkommen,
genau, wir sind führend in der Technik Streaming Branche, weltweit führend, führend im deutschsprachigen
Raum, und schnell wachsend, ja, das müsste ich mir echt ins Profil schreiben, der Chat
ist
ist schlecht. Agile. Ja, ja, Agile.
Cliffhanger richtig.
Oh, Ballchops. Warum habe ich das eigentlich noch offen?
Oh nee, das Pepega-Board ist ja kaputt jetzt. Ich habe die VM ausgeschaltet.
Das läuft ja in der VM. Wir sind nicht das Center of Excellence,
wir sind das Center of Debating.
VM ist aus.
Bei diesen Titeln kannst du auch Katja Grasawice, kannst auch ApoRed gucken.
Digga.
Oder was sagt er sonst noch immer?
Lass mal kurz meinen inneren ApoRed-Channel.
Digga, kritischer Hase meine Freunde. Das war doch jetzt ziemlich original, oder?
Das hat es doch ganz gut getroffen.
Ich sehe ihr seid nicht die passende Zielgruppe anscheinend.
Das ist echt so. Ich kenne auch in Deutschland keinen.
Es gibt jede Menge Channels auf YouTube, die sich Technik-Channels in dem Sinn nennen.
Aber die machen dann Smartphone-Reviews oder sowas.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass Smartphones keine Technik sind.
Aber für mich ist das kein Technik-Channel.
Linus Technips ist für mich auch so an der Grenze.
Da geht es vom Inhalt her, es kommen technische Sachen in den Videos vor.
Es ist aber Technik-Entertainment. Und das macht er auch so gut wie sonst keiner.
Es spricht auch nicht umsonst so viel an.
Ich gucke nicht oft, aber wenn ich gucke, finde ich es immer lustig und gut gemacht.
Der Bauer gibt es noch, der macht was Hardware angeht, ziemlich gute Videos.
Es gibt auch ein paar kleinere Channels, die Sachen programmieren und machen.
Aber sowas in der Richtung gibt es eigentlich nicht.
Also Leute, habt ihr das gehört? Wir sind führend und schnell wachsend im deutschsprachigen Raum.
Industrie-Leading, genau.
Rampage67 sagt, es gibt auf Twitch einen Kanal, was Cannabis-Zucht zeigt.
Es gibt auch einen Kanal, der eine Kamera an seinem 3D-Drucker drin hat.
Und im Titel eine Frage drin steht, was wird das?
Und ich weiß nicht, ob man was gewinnen kann, wenn man das errät.
Es gibt auf Twitch, vor allem wenn man auch mal hier in Science & Technology guckt, gucken wir doch gerade mal.
Wir müssen demnächst mal eh jemand hosten.
Es gibt auch ganz gute deutschsprachige Sachen.
Es gibt sogar auf Twitch, im deutschsprachigen Raum habe ich letztens gesehen,
es gibt sogar ein paar Mädels, die Programmier-Streams machen.
Ich habe mir gedacht, was ist denn hier kaputt? Ganz ganz seltene Sachen.
Ja, Haselmeyer, das stimmt. Es gibt auch genug Channels mittlerweile auf Twitch, was Gaming anbelangt.
Von Mädels, wo es nicht um Boob-Cam geht.
Gott sei Dank, das hat lange genug gedauert.
Radeon RX 5700 XT-Kühler-Upgrade, da wollen wir mal gucken.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall MonkaS aus.
Wollen wir den hosten?
Oh, German Bash Scripting.
Bash Scripting in Atom, das ist auch mal was Neues. Wobei, ist das überhaupt Atom? Das ist VS Code.
Komm, wir hosten den Kühler-Upgrader.
Also Leute, benehmt euch ordentlich und wünscht ihm mal, dass es nicht MonkaS smoket.
Wir sehen uns morgen, machts gut. Bis denn, see you.